Blitz salut à tous salut stuff bon ça va
être cool aujourd'hui c'est tout on
passe en mode éclair c'est clair donc on
a 12 parties aujourd'hui de 3 + 2 avec
un mvl qui est champion du monde entier
on va voir un petit peu si un vel arrive
à conserver son titre
donc parmi par miam réel il y a quand
même encore toute la panoplie de grand
maître en présente qui était déjà hier
au rapide donc on a Carlson Epone Naka
on a vraiment tout le monde donc là
c'est vraiment un journaliste qui
s'annonce palpitant Kévin oui on a fait
comme d'hab vous le savez nos petits
pronos d'ailleurs on s'était bien bien
planté au niveau du rapide
néanmoins avec stouf on était d'accord
sur le numéro 1 on disait que ça allait
être Carlsen bon vous savez on n'avait
pas pris grand risque et maman se
craquant légèrement sur la fin de
tournoi il a quand même remporté le
tournoi seul donc grosse facilité quoi
pas trop de soucis là dessus il a été
intraitable et donc pour aujourd'hui
c'est un autre c'est un autre jeu c'est
un autre cadence c'est un autre tournoi
on va voir un petit peu vraiment comment
comment ça se passe mais car c'est en
tout cas si il continue sur ce niveau de
forme il va être dur à aller chercher
exactement on peut vous parler des de
nos autres favoris pour le tournoi donc
toi tu verrais bien un éponyachi en
deuxième place de ce Blitz tandis que
j'ai mis Nakamura c'est ça
mais tu nous parles de Nakamura parce
que tu le vois bien troisième et moi
j'ai dîné pomatchi donc globalement on
est assez d'accord sur les trois gros
favoris on n'a pas oublié un VL on avait
tous les deux mis en cinquième position
donc finalement tu as changé tu l'as mis
en quatrième position mvl pour ma part
j'ai mis un
ergaliser très en forme que tu as mis 5e
pour ce Blitz et moi j'ai mis mvl en 5e
place pour la défense de son titre voilà
comment on voit les choses donc là
aujourd'hui on va voir 12 rondes de 3
plus 2 et tu me disais sauf que c'était
à peu près une partie à la demi-heure
oui c'est ça en tout cas les horaires
sont prévus chaque demi-heure il y a une
partie donc c'est encore une fois
difficile de garder ce rythme en tant
qu'ordinateur donc il y aura sûrement un
peu de retard sur les parties mais
normalement chaque demi-heure il y a une
partie donc on va suivre en priorité
Maxime qui est quand même est français
et surtout échantillon du monde donc
après on verra un petit peu à ce que ce
qu'on suit malheureusement Maxime il n'y
a pas de caméra encore une fois il est
il est je sais plus combien de Tiem sur
la ligne de départ je vais vous dire ça
tout de suite
il est 10e
départ donc on a que quatre caméras
enfin que donc malheureusement on n'a
pas on n'a pas de caméra sur lui mais
bon
faible que vous connaissez forfait toute
proportion gardée mais en tout cas on
coupe le tableau en deux et on va dire
que sur un tableau à 100 joueurs le
numéro 1 joue contre le numéro 51
donc là les matchs sont plutôt
déséquilibrés même si c'est grand maître
contre grand maître mais c'est pas des
grands maîtres de même standing et après
ça va s'équilibrer les meilleurs joueurs
les 8 meilleurs joueurs à chaque fois
sont retransmis au niveau des caméras
donc ça nous suffira bien
si Maxime veut être champion du monde
aujourd'hui il va passer par la casse
caméra très clairement c'est ça donc là
du coup on voit sur
bizarre
en tout cas pour cette première ronde
puisqu'on voit c'est vrai que les gens
sont installés un défilement des joueurs
là tu t'arrives à nous mettre une
nouvelle fonction apparemment
oui apparemment sont en train de de Me
je pense que les parties ils ont en
train d'arriver sur James gum et salut
les lève tôt salut tous ceux qui sont
arrivés salut à tous déjà
merci à vous
c'est cool et puis peut-être pour voir
aussi l'événement parce que l'événement
il a une bonne il a une bonne gueule
au-delà de voir notre robinet
franchement l'événement il est il est
pas mal alors qu'on va
à la caméra
douter avec les Noirs vous connais pas
Swan
c'est bien un truc mais je
attends j'ai un bug malheureusement
les joueurs sont prêtes
petite petite blague entre guillemets on
n'a pas réussi à déterminer pourquoi
mais dans la catégorie Femme les femmes
jouent 17 rondes au lieu de 21 dans le
tournoi mixte
c'est peut-être ça la
raison mais je Charlie sylvetto pour te
faire quelques petites blagues il va pas
te rattraper il s'est dit tiens le voilà
tu as vu un malade là pour nous il est
pas venu pour l'événement
il vient pour nous voilà
et
du coup du coup non salut Charlie
Maurice salut pas de Massana salut à
tous les gars
j'espère que vous allez bien dans ce en
ce jeudi matin voilà j'espère que vous
êtes chaud parce qu'on voit le coup
d'envoi a été lancé
sans doute par un dirigeant casaque
et là on va on va bientôt démarrer
alors je vais quand même en vrai un
petit message
pour leur demander de changer le titre
sur twitch parce que malheureusement moi
je n'ai pas accès sinon on va nous le
dire on sait très bien que ce titre
n'est pas bon on sait que vous allez
un coup d'envoi a été réalisé aussi dans
la section mixte
et du coup on va bientôt on va bientôt
démarrer côté français vous savez il y a
Jules Moussa et Sébastien Mazet qui sont
bien bien présents avec Sébastien Mazet
qui aura fort à faire dès la première
ronde puisqu'il joue cheparinov donc qui
était secondante Topalov joueur a plus
de 2600 presque 2700 voilà donc très
très dangereux pour Sébastien dès le
début dès le début de tournois surtout
que Sébastien
c'est pas un gros aficionados du Blitz
preuve en est son classement vite c'est
24 31 c'est moins de moi donc c'est pas
lourd voilà
et
aristan
Isan soul of pour Jules Moussard Jules
aura les pièces noir c'est un joueur à
moins de 2400 donc là c'est c'est
complètement jouable pour pour Jules qui
sera grand favori de cette première
ronde Jules qui peut nourrir des
ambitions dans ce tournoi là ça serait
une surprise mais c'est vrai qu'il est
hyper dangereux en partie extrêmement
rapide donc tout le mal qu'on lui
souhaite c'est de faire un tournoi la
Vincent Kemer hier
je pense que Jules est capable de faire
enfin de créer une grosse surprise dans
un événement comme ça parce qu'il est il
est un peu imprévisible il est capable
de tout s'il est en forme il est
vraiment très très dur à jouer donc moi
je me souviens à l'époque les Blitz
entre mvl et Jules c'était vraiment un
très très impressionnant et j'ai eu il
est capable de les chercher
un podium clairement dans dans cet
endroit
qui en fait qui m'explique un petit peu
la raison de de sa venue matinale je
trouve en disant on s'attendait à ce
stuff en pyjama Pikachu enroulé dans une
moustiquaire pour chat c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est levé et là juste à ce moment
là Néandertal est arrivé elle nous a dit
bonjour tout le monde il tombe bien
Néandertal pour pour avoir ta réponse
parce que je pense qu'il l'attend lui
aussi et ça lui à toi pas de métal salut
à tous ceux qui arrivent en tout cas
ben écoute le Pikachu ça a été compliqué
je suis pas allé je ne suis pas allé au
carrefour de tel des comme je t'ai dit
donc c'était un peu plus compliqué et la
moustiquaire et ben écoute on pas de
nouvelles on n'a pas on n'a pas fait
hier
une journée de reposer par contre demain
ça risque de repartir je pense que c'est
comme coup que ce soit fait avant le 31
donc du coup
il y a moyen que demain ça part et les
parties ont commencé donc on va aller
voir du coup mvl qui du coup a disparu
de chez moi hop on a reparti donc du
coup mvl qui part sur un sur un premier
D4 premier coup donc bon il a une grosse
marge pour cette première partie en
Bolton c'est un c'est un bon grand
maître mais mais ok normalement maxime
est l'argent favori dans cette partie
pour pour tout vous dire il y a une
vidéo qui traîne sur Facebook sur
Facebook
sur sur YouTube sur ma chaîne Youtube où
j'ai fait un match contre Amman umbleton
l'adversaire de mvl et on ajoute pendant
une heure et demie ensemble et le score
était très serré entre lui et moi donc
vous imaginez bien que que mvl contre ce
sera normalement ça doit être ça doit
être
assez normal quoi c'est tranquille quoi
le joueur en face est stable mais bon il
a les blancs en plus et déjà il a joué
une ouverture un peu son risque mvl avec
ses fous des deux un peu modernes contre
l'animzo et maintenant il va juste
développer ses pièces assurément Rocket
rapidement
et avoir le petit plus de l'ouverture
ce genre de système pas de risque voilà
il met la tour en C1 ça fait vraiment
penser au grand bidame mais on a juste
retardé la sortie du foussin qu'on a mis
seulement des deux
c'est vraiment sans risque on joue aux
échecs une minute d'avance quasiment
donc c'est cool
pour lui normalement non alors nvl qui
qui est connu surtout en blitz pour
remettre la pression au temps et jouer
du coup très très vite donc on va voir
un petit peu ce qui se passe
malheureusement j'ai toujours pas la
caméra sur mvl vous le savez je suis
encore une fois checker là on est on a
la caméra
en caméra et table 1
covallev qui attend 45
personnes qui est pas encore arrivé
incroyable
parce que évidemment est-ce qu'il a
qu'il a démarré la pendule de la pendule
j'imagine qu'elle est démarrée pour tout
le monde je ne la vois pas je vais voir
si je peux avoir une caméra plus grande
juste pour moi
parce que c'est logique normalement là
il y a pour moi il y a pas de passe
droit
qui arrive et je pense que le temps oui
non ouais la pendule a été lancée car
scène qui a moitié en pyjama est-ce que
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être juste
voir la partie de caresses pour voir le
temps qu'il a s'il te plaît souffre
parce que je pense qu'il a pas beaucoup
de temps je vais vous mettre je vais
vous mettre la vue la plus grande que
j'ai avec
la personne qui est en jogging
c'est sympa le jogging moi aussi pour
tout dire sauf j'ai mis un petit jogging
aujourd'hui c'est pas un jour de finale
et je sais pas si il a 35 secondes
à la pendule
c'est ouf c'est assez rigolo ce qui
vient de se passer et joue un très fort
grand maître en plus covalef c'est plus
de 2600 donc c'est fort
in même en feed donc et 30 secondes à la
pendule c'est c'est un ultra Berserk
pour ceux qui connaissent
est-ce que tu veux suivre celle-là ou tu
veux revenir sur sur ml quand même
j'avoue allez au chat de nous dire parce
que vous voulez voir le est-ce que vous
voulez voir le Berserk de
scène où est-ce que vous préférez
[Musique]
c'est une structure Stonewall où les
Noirs ont perdu leur foodcase noire donc
c'est déjà une bonne poubelle pour le
joueur noir une minute de moins
et ça serait intéressant de voir si
Carlson va réussir à retourner covalev
avec du temps en moins
je vous mets la l'échiquier et bien par
contre je garde où j'ai plein de
personnes aussi
je trouve qu'il joue pas avec beaucoup
de malice pour moi il aurait dû jouer
bon et ben c'est très clair en fait
entre Magnus et aller Magnus pour celle
là il y en a qui sont prêts à faire des
concessions
3 4 5 6 7 on a 7 45 contre 3 4 nvl
et juste pour cela moi ça m'intéresse ça
m'intéresse carcienne juste pour
celle-là parce que du coup il y a
il est où
je trouve qu'il a pris trop de temps
regardez et pas normal il aurait dû là
maintenant il joue à 55 ans puisque
Magnus a joué très rapidement et que
voilà
c'est pas malin ce qu'il a fait il a
laissé revenir à 30 alors vous allez me
dire oui mais Kevin attention il joue
Carlson c'est compliqué non mais
il a joué une une Française d'échange et
il a rien obtenu après on secoue en plus
elle est décidé de choses plus
compliquées pour 45 plutôt que de jouer
un truc aussi simple bien sûr et plus
plus rapidement surtout c'est ça que je
décris je touche je suis sûr que tu lui
aurais mis la pression longtemps à
Magnus dans quoi
mais non mais là il se retrouve à 30
secondes chacun au bout de 12 coups et
peut-être qu'il a voulu lui rendre la
politesse il respecte beaucoup peut-être
qu'il a fait exprès pour lui rendre le
temps parce que voilà mais bon
car ça nous parle c'est pas ta faute
quoi enfin c'est pas ton problème quoi
toi il faut que tout le temps parties
donc
ce qu'on sait que Carlsen pour faire des
speed chasse il est pas mal à droite
avec un incrément 2 secondes donc on dit
pas qu'il aurait gagné facilement on lui
mettre en impression longtemps mais
c'est à saisir cette opportunité
en fait à la partie ce qui est assez
incroyable je trouve c'est pour ça que
gallinor qu'on avait dit qu'on suivait
Maxime sans aucun souci mais là on fait
une petite entorse à notre à notre
discours parce que cette partie rigolote
de voir un carlin de démarrer avec aussi
peu de temps et prendre l'avantage
autant
[Musique]
on va changer un peu de vue je vais
essayer de vous mettre l'autre vu pour
voir un peu si on arrive à voir le vrai
temps des joueurs parce que là sur
cheesecom c'est pas si clair
et on voit ouais c'est à peu près ça il
y a trois secondes pour 4 secondes à 10
et là vous voyez la position qui est qui
est en bas à gauche elle est pas très
très grande mais on voit quand même
assez grand
qu'une personne qui met la pression
qui est actif là de fou le roi qui ouvre
le cavalier 1 dominé par le fouet 5 et
il va le travailler maintenant de bout
en bout des quatre premiers 4 du coup il
avait pu en BD en prise puis on D4 aussi
faible
[Musique]
avec si peu de temps la pendule je vois
bien qu'un scène gagnant Kevin
je pense que Carlson a acheté le pack
sur l'initiative et du coup il est
peinard maintenant
dans toutes les positions non mais il a
trouvé des choses qu'on va faire
évidemment regarder il a réussi à
ramener le cavalier
on sait qu'il allait le faire caresses
mais c'est pas si simple sauf le
cavalier 3 il est revenu il est revenu
en jeu
il y a une répétition avec la tour B3
tourbé 4 et 45 finalement qui décide de
faire trois quatre pour continuer à
jouer
qui est égal mais oui qui peut faire un
bon F5 et très pénible à surveiller lors
des prises
un mec sur ce pion aussi c'est pas c'est
pas si évident là
pourrait poser des problèmes
il peut aussi se faire enfermer sa tour
tout est possible
elle finit par jouer
quelques secondes chacun
et Carlson qui qui a réussi à provoquer
un café français
parce que ça sentait très mauvais de
jouer ça quoi c'est bizarre c'est pas
les dents c'est bizarre je pense qu'il y
a il y a un profond respect pour Carson
parce que c'est pas normal qu'il fasse
des erreurs comme ça
l'échange à ce niveau là ça a l'air
quand même assez
donc oui c'est pas facile d'accepter
mais
c'est quand même pas très beau
confirmer même pour un joueur comme
Carsen à sept pendule ça va vite de
tomber pour les deux joueurs
il a vraiment il a vraiment merdouillé
qu'on va la parce que
et abandon on va repartir vite sur
carcennes sur voilà mvl qui est qui a
gagné
sa partie on est vraiment désolé pour
pour avoir choisi aujourd'hui
enfin cette partie là Karlsen amvl mais
il y avait cet enjeu cette partie que
vous êtes arrivé est arrivé en retard de
quasiment 3 minutes on a bien confiance
au Maxime aussi ça qu'on peut dire ouais
c'est ça
j'ai ma caméra qui ne marche pas
par contre je sais pas trop si tu as de
la neige mais normalement tu es hyper
bien quoi
c'est bien plaisir en tout cas on va
partir sur Kawana du coup
je vois la jauge je leur dis qu'il dit
que c'est facilement gagner je voudrais
pas été aussi évidemment
ce que je peux jamais me sacrifier mon
pion
sacré mon cavalier sur le pion reste en
comme ça se fait dans cavalier pion
roi contre roi cavalier donc là ça va
gagner en tournant c'est ça la
différence c'est notre position G4
cavaliers F5 c'est la clé il y a plein
de transposition plein d'échanges de
cavaliers gagnants
ça c'est clair on a aussi donc à ce qui
gagne pour les favoris c'est pas
normalement bien passé j'ai l'impression
quelques en route tu as du bofle c'est
quand même assez dépend un petit peu des
c'est quand même très fort quoi
c'est assez récent donc il y a des
joueurs des fois ils ont des classements
bizarres
on vous le rappelle donc globalement
c'est
oui c'est pas du tout random pour pour
l'appareil man franchement pas du tout
c'est l'appareil manque forfait comme je
disais tout à l'heure on imagine un
tableau de 100 joueurs le numéro 1 je
vous raconte le 51
alors on a une partie qui était marrante
qui se terminait c'est darda qui vient
de battre fedo segaf tarde le joueur le
joueur belge qui vient de battre du coup
ce dossier fais hier qui était dans en
course pour le podium du championnat du
monde de rapides il reviendra parce que
les petits jeunes sur une partie on a
Sébastien Mazet qui joue toujours aussi
ça ça partit on va lui mettre le côté
noir heureusement on lui porte pas
bonheur parce que là le pion des 6 il va
devenir grand
café nul
rien à faire si le roi se rapproche
c'est pas vous voyez il vient de faire
un nul bon c'est pas une grosse opé mais
bon est-ce que ça a été signé
je pense que oui
permet aux pions de faire survivre le
joueur du cru le joueur kazak
et du coup les parties ce sont ce sont
terminés donc on a démarré on a démarré
je sais pas ça de ronde à 10h05 à peu
près je pense je peux pas regarder
l'heure et on voit qu'à 10h20 il reste
pas grand chose donc du coup c'est
environ comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est une demi-heure par partie à peu
près la rampe qui un quart d'heure je
pense mais
normalement il est parti qui peut
vraiment durer plus longtemps parce que
parce que du coup
voilà il y a des parties qui vont durer
plus longtemps etc
gros travail pour les arbitres
aujourd'hui oui apparemment ça va vite
ça enchaîne et puis voilà quoi
complètement donc du coup il a commenté
c'est un peu plus difficile parce que ça
va vite ça va vite et puis
et puis on a pas le temps nous de voir
forcément tout ce qui se passe
on se focalisant sur les meilleurs on va
quand même bien se régaler honnêtement
c'est assez animé à chaque fois il se
passe un truc
Magnus pour cette ronde un qui le
jugeait peut-être pas très rigolote pour
nous à commenter il a décidé d'arriver
en retard histoire de mettre un peu de
suspense merci à lui et du coup
franchement on était assez impatient de
commenter de ça avec tout on trouve ça
rigolo quoi du speechasse ça ressemble
en fait ça ça va vite et ça enchaîne
vite et du coup c'est pour ça qu'on est
enfin que je trouve que c'est plus sympa
regardez pour vous il y a moins de
commentaires on va dire pédagogiques
mais c'est plus impressionnant donc
c'est plus spectacle en fait aujourd'hui
donc du coup je trouve ça plutôt cool en
fait à suivre comme événement
disons que je fais une partie de trois
plus deux on va dire qu'il y a les
quatre premières minutes qui sont pédago
et une dès qu'on rentre sous la minute
ça va vraiment trop vite quoi
ça va même vite avant mais bon de
rentrer dans les dans les détails
exactement on va pas aller voir
peut-être pendant que pendant que que
les appareils mangent se font on l'a pas
vu en détail
jouer un système j'ai l'impression que
mvl vient nous donner un système un peu
clé en main pour jouer contre la Nimzo
juste aux échecs
aucune difficulté bon là un bâton et il
a craqué de donner à case 5 sur noir
avec ce F5 mais en même temps qu'est-ce
qu'il pouvait jouer peut-être il aurait
dû prononcer trois je trouvais ça plus
naturel
manger
la part de fou mais je veux F5 en fait
il veut avoir une position de type
Stonewall un mur de pierre avec lequel
on joue sans foutage
centrales sans que c'est 5
est-ce qu'il y avait son titre bah on
espère bien en tout cas on n'est pas
visionnaire mais on espère bien en tout
cas
sur les ouvertures à choisir en blitz
pour moi c'est des ouvertures qu'on doit
très bien connaître et idéalement des
ouvertures on pourrait mettre la
pression
j'ai je dirais que la prise d'initiative
est encore plus valorisée en partie de
Blitz puisque l'adversaire a moins le
temps de défendre de trouver les bons
coups de défense il est pris à la gorge
là ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il y a
comme un fil rouge de la partie de mvl
qui est basé sur l'attaque du pion
arrière C6 donc on disait qu'on n'a pas
faire de structures d'option même dans
ce blé de cela mvl a montré qu'il
travaillait sur la structure ils sont
capables les joueurs de jouer des
parties très stratégiques alors qu'ils
sont en partie de Blitz par contre le
final a l'air
peut-être plus recentrer sur l'attaque à
la colonne G on va voir au final ça
s'est joué tactiquement chez Maxime avec
petite petite
tactique sympa avec tout reprend H6 donc
on a vu que sur cavalier prend Tour
Blanche il y avait une fourchette
malheureusement c'est un coup illégal je
peux pas manger ma propre auto
libérer la case pour pouvoir faire en
fait la fourchette ici donc il y a 12
parties aujourd'hui
ultérieure et 21 en tout ouais 12 et 9
voilà c'est ça a été quasiment abandon
un dernier fuite
qui arrive ou même dame G8 plutôt c'est
un patron à coup un peu plus précis donc
mdr qui a qui a fait une très très
grosse première partie dans ce
championnat du monde de Blitz pardon et
donc plutôt en forme
oui oui et puis il a quand même bien
fini son rapide donc il est pas non plus
il a pas été ridicule en rapide s'il a
juste
oui il a juste mal démarré puis un
milieu tournoi un petit peu difficile
aussi et puis il est super bien revenu
sur la fin pour faire trois sur quatre
un nul de victoire et une nul contre à
l'arrache contre Kemer mais il arbitré
le titre de champion du monde hier au
final parce que sans s'annule Kemer
avait la droite
en grande finale en match de partage
d'ailleurs
je descends je descends je descends je
veux pas de drapeau allemand ah si je
l'ai vu il a gagné
difficilement sans doute dans une finale
de dames
on voit la partie caméra ici
il a rendu le pion
généralement dans ces positions
généralement c'est quand même plutôt bon
signe pour oui
tu es faible donc les blancs auraient dû
mettre la pression mais il était bien
plus fort que mer que son adversaire
d'ailleurs
c'est qu'à ce moment là il y avait une
minute d'écart autant qui prouve bien
que mer est en difficulté mais il a
réussi à planter une taxe
c'est quand même fort dommage grosse
folle
[Musique]
un peu trop vite
et qu'elle va aller prendre un F2 bah
oui encore une fois la tour en prise
derrière oulala ça perd tout hein à ce
moment-là tous les coups du tennis ça
perd tout
il a vraiment converti facilement ça
donc grosse faute de l'adversaire avec
même configuration de Carlson quand il a
fauteuil hier sauf que là il avait il
avait moins de temps quand même il avait
une minute 15 contre 15 secondes et il a
offert la victoire à Vincent Kemer en
faisant une grosse bourre tactique ça
arrive très souvent quand même sous
pression du temps avec l'accélération
des cadences
comment faire je pense que c'est Nathan
merci beaucoup pour avoir changé les
titres on ne pouvait pas on n'avait pas
la main dessus malheureusement et oui
il a gagné il a pas eu son numéro
elle doit dormir d'accord ok bon merci
Samy
c'est l'un ou l'autre
ça c'est bizarre hein
Kevin
oui ça m'a l'air très bizarre
[Musique]
un peu ouais
de jouer une sorte de C3 système pour
retransposer dans des pierres mais avec
ces trois cartes quoi
en prise derrière c'est un peu compliqué
à perdre comme comme pion le pion B2 et
là on voit neiman il a les meilleures
pièces par rapport à ça
du coup il améliore et il reste un
épisode adverse et convertit ça par le
gains
difficile de le défendre parce que foub2
il y a tour des deux si j'avance la case
des quatre aussi
en ayant de meilleures pièces souvent on
arrive à faire la différence et là ça a
été ça a été la kermesse après
une grosse partie du du joueur serbe qui
s'est bien fait atomiser
donc non pour l'instant les favoris sont
toujours en tête
il y a pas eu trop de surprises il y a
pas eu de grosses défaites je crois on a
eu quelques nuls mais des nuls tu as bon
Artémis par avion c'est moi c'est pas
une grosse merde
peut-être un petit peu mais bon ça reste
quand même des petits surprises mais ça
reste assez marginal ouais une petite
news c'est possible mais tu vois il y a
un joueur qui veut me battre un 2006 là
il y a une contrepèze c'est parti là
un petit peu la chronique c'est une
astuce j'ai perdu une partie horrible
contre
guéri ah oui avec trois pions
sur une sorte de maths en deux coups
enfin la totale quoi alors qu'il avait
fait une super partie donc il est
capable ce joueur toujours allemand qui
était vraiment très bien d'ailleurs
toute la partie pour l'instant il a un
pionate de plus il est en train de faire
une grosse partie
les pieds dans le papier ici
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
pour lui
pas réussi à convertir la barre de fou
quand ça s'ouvre ça peut être
une pièce
parce que du coup faut à 5 ça clou le
cavalier
sur la même diago
je perds je perds la pièce si je défends
avec le roi il y a E4 et du coup je
perds ma tour en mettant le fond en deux
il y avait 4 et j'ai pas de cases pour
mon cavalier pour venir défendre le fou
malheureusement j'ai pas regardé Jeanne
qui avait des quatre donc quand je bouge
le cavalier et ben je perds le fou donc
là bas il perd une pièce
qui dit que ça résonne trop quand tu
cliques ça va être difficile pour ce de
pas cliquer il va falloir qu'on lui
achète une souris silencieuse dans ce
cas là c'est pas facile je vais baisser
attendez ben je vais pas nous dire si
vous avez des remarques tout ça si vous
voulez voir une partie en particulier si
vous voulez voir un joueur français on
va suivre mvel en priorité mais on a dit
qu'on espérait quand même que Jules
Moussa crée la surprise
c'est cool parce que c'est pas
impossible sur un tournoi il a le niveau
il a le talent et en blitz c'est quand
même une bonne machine de guerre donc
s'il est en forme et en confiance ça
peut vraiment le faire le tout étant de
de démarrer correctement pour prendre
confiance parce que on rappelle qu'il y
a beaucoup de joueurs qui ne sont pas
maladroit
dans ce tournoi et c'est un euphémisme
sont dangereux on a en Drake in par
exemple qui est dans ce tournoi qu'on a
pas cité de joueurs très très forts
est très très dangereux bien sûr on a
aussi
karwana qu'on a vu beaucoup progresser
on avait commenté avec stouf on a vu
qu'il était devenu hyper dangereux on a
NiAl Sarine le copain de
very guysi qui est mon partenaire de
club à Mulhouse enfin les deux sont
partenaire de club à Mulhouse je peux
vous dire qu'ils font pour s'amuser
quand on est à l'hébergement le soir des
petits 10 secondes chacun donc les mecs
ils en bouffent des échecs je peux vous
dire
on vient de citer fedocef qui avait
perdu contre darda darda c'est un jeune
qui monte même si les queues 2600 je dis
que 2600 par rapport à ce tournoi là
mais n'a pas dit son dernier mot on n'a
pas cité non plus ma médié Rohff mamedia
Rohff le joueur asiatique qui est très
très connu je l'avais vu en Championnat
du Monde jeune faire tourner tous les
jeunes de la délégation parce que lui
c'était un des plus grands c'était pas
grave j'étais en moins de 18 et moins de
20 ans c'est en moins de 18 ans qui
s'amuse à faire ça il jouait tous les
jeunes de sa délégation
et il faisait des une minute contre 5
minutes voilà donc c'est des joueurs qui
ont vraiment une expérience incroyable
on a
Ian Christophe Douda on a à Nice guéri
aussi tous ces joueurs là sont très
forts faut pas oublier artemief du bof
mon bref vous avez vu le plateau tous
les meilleurs joueurs du monde sont là
il y a que car Yakine finalement qui est
pas là qui on va jouer à qui n'est pas
là stuff qui n'est pas là bas
il manque les raisins il manque
[Musique]
pas ce qu'on ne connaît
ça c'est vrai tous les participants du
speechasse on a dit qu'ils étaient hyper
dangereux
souvent dans la question par rapport à
les raisins vous savez pas
non mais
pour les joueurs aussi c'est une période
un peu un peu particulière
avec les fêtes de fin d'année etc et il
y en a qui point Blitz rapide ne se
déplace pas il préfère se concentrer sur
leur carrière en l'an avec les tournois
les plus riches mon hôtel et la
valorisation réelle de la progression
pour aller au 3 des candidats pour faire
partie du vrai circuit mondial et
aller vers le titre de champion du monde
en cadence Rennes c'est-à-dire en
cadence lente c'est ça donc là j'ai
apparemment c'est intéressant
un gros choc par rapport à hier tu vois
c'est un appareillement qui aurait pu se
jouer lors de la dernière ronde du
Championnat du Monde rapide hier pour
pour une belle place au podium on a
Kemer contre Carolin
ensuite bon on a plein de matchs
intéressants mais Maxime qui gagne deux
places qui étaient une table 10 qui
balance rentable 8 il a pas un
apparemment facile et je joue le petit
mourzine François
c'est un jeune qui a 16 ans on a parlé
hier il a quasiment 2600 os et
et donc il a fait un super temps
d'ailleurs en rapide il est il est chaud
un profil à la marque André morizy en
peut-être encore plus fort donc en tout
cas pour le moment on espère que
Marc-André va le dépasser mais Morzine
c'est pas rigolo
après en blitz quand même un VL est
complètement favori dans cette partie
bien sûr même avec les Noirs donc donc
c'est clairement pas c'est pas free hein
faut faire attention mais pour cette
ronde de
ouais ensuite niveau français on a Jules
qui a fait nul à la pharmacie qui joue
un mi à 2345
donc encore une fois il est ultra favori
il aura les blancs et Sébastien mazet
avec sa défaite et ben il affronte
donc c'est pas un appareil allemand
facile non pas du tout
[Musique]
s'il commence avec deux bulles c'est en
plus c'est dur un petit peu de se
remettre parce qu'il y a que des matchs
difficiles donc va falloir falloir
accepter donc là ce serait bien qu'il
réagisse avec les pièces blanches
il est fort en théorie
Seb il va peut-être
réussir à bloquer dès le début son
adversaire en tout cas c'est tout le mal
qu'on lui souhaite après c'est un tout
est possible et
puis on va voir ce qui se passe on a je
Bava qui joue contre dommageki c'est un
c'est une partie intéressante bonne
journée gros dent mon travail
à bientôt
on a Sarine
[Musique]
c'est c'est le grand maître bon qui il
est américain il a à peine 2550 à peu
près et en rapide des Blitz c'est une
enfin surtout ambulette d'ailleurs c'est
une fusée c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde de partir de partie Bleach et
Bullet et donc là il joue table 12
contre Amin Bassem donc il a gagné ma
première partie 1 contre un contre un
joueur à 2200 donc il a un sur un et on
va voir un peu ce qui nous réserve dans
ce tournoi c'est un genre qui peut être
dangereux aussi
complètement donc là on a beaucoup de
joueurs très très dangereux
sur ce tableau et on a Maxime qui va
jouer du coup contre murzin donc on n'a
pas la caméra
sur Maxime mais on va essayer
la rondeur va commencer à incessamment
honnêtement là on voit pas les joueurs
encore racis ils ont pris un peu de
retard une dizaine de minutes au
démarrage avec les petites cérémonies
officielles mais tout devrait rentrer
dans l'ordre petit à petit et du coup
allez je dis dans deux minutes ça
commence
là on a les je vais voir si on a une
caméra sur sur la salle
à vous montrer je vais vous montrer dans
la caméra de la salle comme ça on verra
des joueurs
je sais pas si vous la voyez oui qui va
commencer ouais
on va à une Bassem qui était sur
ce serait cool que un pseudo idées soit
plus polish s'il te plaît ça fait quand
même depuis plusieurs jours que que tes
messages sont très très
très comment dire
pas très sympathique donc je fais un peu
l'effort avec toi mais juste les choses
tu peux lui demander avec un air un peu
plus sympa s'il te plaît merci
j'avais pas vu non mais bon c'est
toujours pareil toujours c'est déjà
c'est là c'est déjà là la première chose
que tu arrives enfin que tu peux dire
quand tu arrives sur un stream et puis
juste prends la parole pour se plaindre
à chaque fois que tu fais un truc juste
voilà quoi
c'était pas très étayé en plus non bon
juste tu vois tu peux demander les
choses poliment quoi en fait plutôt que
de d'arriver juste et de râler de
t'embêter un peu tout le monde
la magie d'internet
donc on est passé en est gentil mais
juste
voilà et salut
s'il avait modéré s'il y avait modéré
cette chaîne il aurait été il aurait été
plus dur
donc le parti qui vont commencer là dans
quelques dans quelques secondes
avec les joueurs qui sont tous
prêts on voit on voit MV un premier plan
derrière l'arbitre là
ils sont un peu ils sont un peu
ils sont un peu longs non mais je suis
assez d'accord c'était juste oui mais
oui oui ils sont un peu longs là à se
mettre en place j'espère qu'ils vont se
rôder
qu'ils avaient pris ils acclament pris
une bonne marge
je disais ça se trouve pour dublis de 3
+ 2
trouver que jouer tous les demi-heures
c'est quand même assez cool
bah finalement
on voit que ils sont ils sont aussi à la
cool les arbitres alors la ronde 2 du
coup était prévue à 30 donc on a déjà 10
minutes de retard alors c'est un peu
normal dans ces événements il y a
toujours un peu de retard au niveau de
leur regard tout ça c'est un gros gros
événement donc on pense à la fin de la
journée avoir quand même pas mal de de
ça y est de retard aussi ça envoie un
Maxime il est en mode Petrov
comme il avait fait contre
Sébastien Mazet pour faire une
donc je comprends ce qu'il fait mais il
est vrai que que jouer la pétrole
ça m'a un petit peu de la part de Maxime
parce que c'est plate je pense que tu
penses il veut pas dévoiler je pense
c'est prépa pas jouer c'est sicilien
habituelles
et du coup
bah il joue ce qu'il connaît autrement
je pense du coup la pétrole fait de la
sonde pas mal regardé il estime que pour
bloquer avec les noirs et puis gagner
avec les Blancs c'est pas mal mais oui
tu dois essayer de jouer des positions
comme tu l'as dit tout à l'heure qui ou
tu peux être un peu la pression
je pense que c'est plus ça
après il veut surprendre mais bon enfin
tu quand même ta nageoire que tu connais
quand même très très bien en blitz bon
tu vois tu vas pas te prendre des
grosses prépas dessus enfin après c'est
mon mon avis perso
à la tête du client aussi il se dit
qu'il joue Morzine un petit jeune et que
si joue aux échecs plutôt que
au préparations d'ouverture il devrait
gagner
il doit semer plus technique quand même
même si
Maxime représente la puissance
calculatoire à l'état pur je pense que
vraiment ça va être sur sur slack ça
devrait devrait le jouer un peu de
technique on voit qu'il obtient
finalement une position avec 30 secondes
d'avance où il a pas trop de problèmes
mais la structure étant égale comme nous
disent tous ça va quand même être dur de
faire la différence c'est ça que tout
veut nous dire si après il fait nul
on dirait que le choix était mauvais oui
en fait on va critiquer si ça marche pas
quoi
alors que si ça marche bah on va dire
que c'est le meilleur choix mais
Manu nous demande quelque chose tout il
nous dit mais au fait il y a eu des il y
a eu des
pronos du côté des commentateurs
évidemment on a un tout petit peu parlé
en début de stream stouf il s'est
positionné c'est Carlson nepo Naka mvl
herigasi donc dans l'ordre donc Carlson
nepona mvl herigasi pour stuff et pour
ma part rien de neuf au soleil Carlson
premier Naka Segond nepo troisième Douda
4e je l'avais mis en rapide il m'a pas
souri je le retente et mvel 5e donc on a
plus de pensées MVS sauf mais on a vu un
carlossen trop fort un aka trop fort en
speechs
et dans le cadre de nos petits pronos il
était difficile de les ignorer même si
on est en général assez chauvins dans
nos pronoms alors moi déjà
pour te dire
bien sûr nous on est tous avec un VL on
espère qu'un VL va être champion du
monde après ça c'est juste des pronos
c'est pas du tout mais on est bien sûr
100% avec Maxime si tu avais choisi qui
gagne le championnat je serai bien sûr
avec Maxime alors qui est mort hier il a
fait un super tournoi
le but c'est quand même de différent au
niveau des proba de faire deux fois
podium à son niveau ça m'a l'air un
petit peu beaucoup et c'est pour ça que
pour moi en fait et ben il était pas
question que je le mette en prono ouais
tout à fait et puis ou alors ça voudrait
tout simplement dire simplement dire
qu'il a passé un cap gigantesque même à
cette cadence là sera un signe très fort
d'ailleurs Abdou sa torov l'an dernier
c'était une demi surprise de le voir à
ce niveau là un peu comme caméra cette
année on savait qu'il était très fort
mais il avait confirmé et depuis on voit
qu'il s'installe quand même
dans la hiérarchie mondiale sans être
dans le top 10 mais il se on voit qu'il
commence à se placer
mais il est stable au niveau de ses
résultats
donc
c'est normal aussi qu'on mette unvel
parce que dans les pronos il est quand
même Champion du monde en titre voilà
donc
[Musique]
pas du tout on est malin on veut pas
perdre nos pronos et en terme de
statistiques
Carl scène ils apparaissent aux trois
premières places de de notre chrono
parce que on a deux des champions du
monde contre le le finaliste et on en
aka qui reste le joueur en partie
extrêmement rapide qui est quasiment le
plus fort au monde donc ça c'est
légitime moi la [ __ ] trois tours 3
dames des tomates la pression
va venir ranger deux pour défendre le
cavalier
2 on peut
mettre un pressing ça peut être
compliqué peut-être un fou prendre et un
jour un tour qui peut arriver d'ailleurs
échec mais en préparant pour ça il y a
vraiment il y a toujours le pion à deux
en l'air en plus tout regarde on peut
peut-être
croquer il a mangé ici du coup Caval et
prend F4 je pense on peut peut-être
faire les prend F4 qui attaque H3
F3 ouh là là
la mangea je crois on va rapidement voir
et du coup il a une finale avec un pion
de plus donc tout recettes va venir
quand même pour taquiner un petit peu ce
pion
là
des deux moi-même pour aller manger ses
pions là et ouais tu as une attaque
défense avec toi à 5 aussi qui qui se
tente mais en tout cas il est actif
mais il y a un petit pressing noir
en tout cas
et on voit que Maxime qui a beaucoup de
temps d'avance à la pendule enfin
beaucoup de temps qu'il y a quand même
30 secondes d'avance c'est quand même
pas mal
normalement on dit Wilfried que
l'appauvrissement de la position va
favoriser le temps qui défend
en fait c'est plus facile de défendre
trois tours que roi tourcipion qu'on
droit tour 5 pions c'est une règle
générale qui qui ne vaut pas
tout le temps quoi si tu veux mais en
règle générale ça marche pas mal en tout
cas Maxime doit rester très actif la
problématique c'est que sont trois
comptes 2 pour l'instant n'était pas
valorisés tour des cinq très intéressant
pour tout des deux il doit être actif si
je joue passivement comme ça avec mes
pions que je défends un truc comme ça je
sais pas je vais pas réussir à faire
grand chose il faut activer les tours il
faut aller manger le plus de pion
possible et c'est
50% de chance de gagner 50% de chance de
faire nul une paire de galette un peu
passé mais moi aussi si je mange ici
j'ai quand même trois pions passés donc
faire attention donc un bloc de trois
pions et ça fera mal certainement
là je suis beaucoup plus avancé que que
Morzine
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait là Maxime
arriver là et maintenant c'est pas
simple de vraiment
je pense pour faire quelque chose puis
on prend on reprend super là tant pis
j'aurais tour des six et je vais
travailler
pour garder la tension sur la tour qui
empêche du coup ça
tour B3 pour bloquer
tout de suite
revenir
parce que les pions cavaliers sont les
pierres je l'ai dit hier mais les pions
cavaliers dans le genre position
contre tour c'est nul enfin c'est depuis
en cavaliers c'est les pires honnêtement
on les reconnaît bien et Morzine et il
s'y trompe pas
prise
mais il pourra plus passer je pense un
équivalent de la finale de filière je
peux vous dire que ni l'un ni l'autre je
pense craquer dans cette position
qui est mort qui a fait nul contre
carwana Guerry qui a gagné
bon tous les favoris en fait qui qui
gagne
[Musique]
parce que Morzine il peut jouer comme ça
avec 8 secondes pendant très longtemps
assurément il y a pas de piège en fait
si tu veux
pas la caméra sur sur
avec avec les Blancs ici parce que du
coup à 6 c'est magnifique
donc c'est comme si la pièce de plus en
fait c'est marrant
et lui il ne joue pas là
pas de bol
elle est mignonne et B6 bien sûr on sort
le fou mais au prix d'un gros gros pion
j'ai faim
et du coup ben c'est la finale qu'on a
vu
il fallait peut-être aller chercher le
contre jeu avec gros G4
apparemment c'est la ligne qui fait qui
fait nul mais bon pas évident
en fait tu peux pas partir avec ta pion
tu prends je prends la je prends je
prends lequel d'ailleurs
alors toujours attention bien sûr c'est
pas simple un point F4 sur il avance
trop vite
le roi va rester en F7 je vais mettre
mais c'est pas simple
il faut que je retourne en
F5 non plus
et
ok c'est pas vraiment c'est pas facile
de tout comprendre tout ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué
comme quoi encore une fois en finale
l'activité elle prime vraiment sur sur
les pions c'est vraiment vraiment très
très important de toujours actif
merci mon nom pour ton petit mot et
merci à toi
[Musique]
une bonne petite chanson
de stade de foot j'ai bien aimé j'ai
bien aimé le cocorico tu as dû vibrer
devant la coupe du monde de foot aussi
ça c'est mal passé pour nous j'espère
que Maxime va avoir un
un une femme tournant plus agréable que
nous une fin de coupe du monde de foot
d'ailleurs il y a pas d'argentin qui
participent autrement
c'est le moment de les taper aux échecs
on aimerait bien les voir là on a bien
les voir
[Musique]
il y a plus de partir en cours
donc
on voit encore une petite partie entre
deux joueurs kazak non
c'est des finances c'est les hommes
alors attends ça ressemble à une
position archi nul en plus
c'est pas cadrique dans cette Torfou
alors avant c'est la gueule parce que
chez moi
ah oui c'est ça
ouais je pense et ça a bloqué
c'est moi
elle ne joue plus cette position on a un
bug moi c'est pas impossible mais ça
doit être ça les noirs qui ont 2468
alors que des blancs
normalement on dit un petit draw et vite
fait mais bon les joueurs de haut niveau
quand il s'accorde sur la nul
ça va assez vite enfin les deux joueurs
se regardent presque des fois
effectivement
après les joueurs ou les joueurs se
les joueurs le savant
sa famille
mais c'est juste que les deux forêts je
sais pas qui veut gagner
je vais vous mettre la caméra en plus
grand parce que vu qu'on a pas la partie
au niveau du temps parce que ça peut
être sanctionnant
allez feinte d'un échec et repart
finalement B2 mon G7 là du coup juste
là ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre
voilà il reste protégé avec Poupion
ouais
pas mal le roi essaie de créer un réseau
ouais attention voilà c'est parti on va
repartir elle a plutôt intérêt
avec les Noirs faut pas jouer au con
hein franchement il aurait peut-être
intérêt à répéter voilà danser pas mal
dans mes 7 on peut essayer des petits de
choper le roi qui fait le malin
c'est pas mal ça ces petites config
tu fais jamais rien malheureusement
on laisse jouer attention les joueurs
ils ont 10 secondes à chaque fois
je préférais l'autre vue j'aime bien la
vue pendule moi
mais la cam
passe pas
ça progresse pas voilà ça progresse pas
il y a toujours 10 secondes à peu près
attention que je peux t'enfiler la dame
là
ça pourrait être un drame quand même des
deux côtés ça peut tourner ce genre de
position
vous voyez qu'avec une dame on peut rien
faire avec une dame malheureusement on
peut vraiment rien faire du tout
les blancs continuent
à un moment et de couper les échecs
j'ai toujours
noir à moins pris un peu de temps
faut pas perdre le rythme en fait si
vous voulez dans cette position là ni
pour l'un ni pour l'autre
ils font tourner la machine
il se passerait il se passe rien mais ça
joue
ça fait ça fait
c'est pas combien de coups qui tourne et
au final il faut que tu pousses le pion
avec les Noirs limite c'est les noirs
qui commencent à un jeu pour le gars en
fait à la fin quoi c'est ça que je suis
en train de dire
complètement ils sont battus en tout cas
c'est rigolo
plus ou moins à regarder on voit bien je
pense assez long ouais cadeau c'est ça
le matériel insuffisant non mais ça
c'est long pour
normalement dans les tours en plus
on n'aime pas trop quand c'est long on
n'aime pas perdre le rythme
et là ça va être une journée bien
fatigante pour les joueurs Marc André
est-ce qu'il a le niveau suffisant pour
participer l'événement je suis pas sûr
en fait bon oui pour participer
quasiment oui mais est-ce qu'il a le
droit de participer à l'événement je
crois pas non il faut être 25-50 dans
une cadence donc on pourrait vérifier sa
fiche feed
je vais vous dire mais
il a 2421 en bride c'est rapide et il a
2526 en l'an documents créé 24 points
pour pouvoir participer à l'événement
vous voyez à quel point c'est fort comme
tendance on peut participer que si on a
2550 dans un des trois dans une des
trois on va dire cadence de jeu ou alors
si on est si on est champion de son pays
ou alors qu'on est invité par
l'organisateur ou par la fuite la
condition la plus facile à avoir c'est
le hello Blitz ou le hello rapide
surtout pour un joueur comme Marc-André
le problème c'est qu'il joue pas c'est
cadence là puisqu'il se concentre sur sa
carrière en l'an qui est vraiment la
cadence reine comme je disais tout à
l'heure donc finalement c'est aussi
parce qu'ils ne s'entraîne pas
spécifiquement pour ce genre de de
compétition
qui est parti sur du MP3
ça marche bien parce que les joueurs
sont pas très préparés en face et lui il
arrive à bien passer ses pièces tout le
temps
rapidement
il échange les bonnes pièces à chaque
fois c'est du Magnus dans le texte il
comprend bien quelle pièce est changée
et il arrive à faire la différence sur
cela
sur l'activité les meilleurs pièces et
le travail de autour de tout cela
c'est marrant tu vas quand même jouer
c'est
trop facile tu as l'impression que que
le jeu d'échec est trop facile mais
quand c'est nous qui jouons on se rend
compte que c'est pas si facile que ça
en 3 + 2 il te fait des parties
normale en fait il joue beaucoup mieux
en blitz que nous en fait moi je me
souviens tu sais que jouer sur ambulette
c'est en fait elle
veut énormément ambulaire sur les
chaises et tu sais
tu avais en fait sur XS tu as les senti
pion pour voir un petit peu le le
la différence ok le
[Musique]
plus ta partie est parfaite si tu veux
bien sûr généralement quand tu es à
moins de 10 centipions c'est que tu as
fait soit une partie parfaite soit tu as
mis l'ordi enfin voilà quoi et ouais
c'est la précision et en fait du coup 47
en Bullet contre des joueurs comme avis
resa ou contre des joueurs comme comme
ça rime enfin des produits et bien
chaque partie il faisait moins de 10 ans
en Bullet alors que bon moi une partie
avant de descendu pion je la fais si je
tombe sur une belle prépa que je connais
tu vois mais ça arrive une fois voilà
mais lui c'est à chaque partie et sans
Bullet
c'est nous ça c'est pas que ça nous
équerre parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'admiration comme le présent de souffle
tout ça mais
s'en est écœurant dans le bon sens du
terme on est on est plus admiratifs on
se demande un peu en fait on estime
qu'on joue pas en même jeu quasiment
c'est ça
fait notre très longtemps qu'on joue
avec normalement c'est à peu près
comment tourne les pièces mais carlsan
c'est un magicien du jeu quoi on ne peut
pas rivaliser quoi
ouais je vois que ça te fait plaisir
je me suis douté
dans la file d'or Magnus nous dirait
qu'il y a la paire de fou et que c'est
déjà c'est déjà terminé
oui ça fait déjà des senti plusieurs
mois tout ça se trouve d'avoir choisi la
fille bah oui tu fais E4 dci si tu dis
un précision quoi tu dis ça va ou quoi
en tout cas ça a été une belle leçon de
Maka qui est bon
excusez-moi
alors oui il fait du Bullet donc il
passe un peu pour un un requin du jeu
d'échec mais en fait c'est avant tout un
joueur extrêmement brillant et pas qu'on
cadence rapide
c'est un joueur qui est tout simplement
génial et qui en plus a des qualités
énormes en partie rapide avec des maïs
tactiques etc
mais ici aussi jouer aux échecs simples
c'est à dire là c'était une partie très
positionnée il a pris un petit plus et
après l'écrases en adversaire il sait
tout faire aussi d'accord attention
d'accord
de défense derrière
Naka c'est le genre qui va très souvent
manger le pion quand tu quand toi tu
mangerais pas tu vois il va il aime bien
les petits défis un petit peu à ce
niveau là et
après c'est pas mal de gens modernes qui
ont cette mentalité là stouffe je trouve
que de plus en plus on le voit je me
rappelle avoir vu airgaliser au speed
chasse manger des pions que je n'aurais
même pas regardé enfin je n'aurais même
pas regardé la possibilité de le manger
tellement je trouvais ça scabreux et les
mecs ils y vont et c'est un petit peu
l'ordinateur qui a amené cela qui était
quand même assez matérialiste et qui a
montré au joueur de haut niveau qu'on
pouvait prendre des pions qui paraissent
un petit peu douteux à prendre et après
faut les capacités calculatoires qui
vont avec
je te coupe parce que je viens d'avoir
et on a on a une partie très très
avec mvl contre Kemer mvl blanc contre
Kemer c'est la la revanche d'hier avec
les mêmes couleurs
parce que
très bien passé là il veut passer et
voilà avec un et demi on a aussi
Jules Moussard qui va jouer contre un un
ami iranien qui a 2428 donc voilà les
noirs avec un et demi et on n'a pas vu
Sébastien qui avait perdu il a perdu
contre sen Rasmus et là il va jouer tout
le monde dont on a parlé du Kirghizistan
qui va que j'avais joué avec un chapeau
traditionnel et c'est un joueur assez
modeste
qui vaut à peu près en 2350 en partie
lente donc Sébastien il doit le il doit
c'est très important parce que sinon le
tournoi va être long pour pour Seb alors
que là il a eu deux parties sympa mais
malheureusement cette il avait fort à
faire donc si d'ailleurs
en attendant la partie de Seb je souffre
et andrasian contre Naka donc ça c'est
pour les appareils moins d'en haut après
voilà je sais pas
Niman qui a 200 deux aussi qui joue
pranave
gorillage qui n'a à l'écran alors tu
vois la participation
donc un joueur de haut niveau on se fait
la Rasmus dans 26 60
et l'ouverture des cases blanches en
ligne de mire évidemment puisque les
seuls à avoir le foot casse blanche et
regarder il y arrive voilà le foot 15
blanc chaque activé et c'est ce qui a
fait pencher la balance en sa faveur là
à chaque fois
il a sorti une énorme partie contre Seb
qui a essayé de se défendre mais
malheureusement son roi était blessé
mais je peux pas faire grand-chose
on voit des thèmes de livres en regarder
là c'est le sacrifice positionnel de
qualité avec quelque chose d'énorme et
puis après c'est un fil rouge ou sphin
Rasmus à valoriser son sacrifice de
qualité professionnelle en activant son
fou
distinctif celui que Seb ne possède plus
sur casse blanche et à la fin ce
foodcesse blanche il est encore utile
pour le pion C2 et la faiblesse du roi
blanc magnifique
salut Adel Weiss
je française non on n'a pas le
françaises dans ce dans cet événement et
salut à toi bismatage
du monde de partir rapide de nul rapide
moi
c'est pas un échantillon représentatif
quoi on va pas se mentir sur un tournoi
les mecs peuvent déconner après Naka
voyant qu'il pouvait plus faire premier
il fait des petites nuls avec tout le
monde
et du coup on va suivre du coup notre
mvl national
contre Vincent Kemer auteur d'un d'un
super tournoi hier en rapide vive
champion du monde
[Musique]
à partir de la ronde suivante on aura
les vrais chocs des champions je peux
vous dire que tous ceux qui vont être à
3 sur 3
ça sera il n'y aura que des stars du
Blitz il y aura quasiment plus de
surprises
hier c'était une c'était E5 hier c'était
une expérience c'est son ouverture
fétiche à Québec parce que je le vois
dans la base de données quand je regarde
quand j'étudie la carrocane avec les
élèves généralement c'est ce qu'il joue
variante donc des deux cavaliers avec le
rat des points 4 souvent lui préfère
fujer 4 et du coup dans tu sais un truc
que j'ai proposé dans les répertoires
simples
la carrocane au jour amateur et je
montre exactement cette variante le coup
c'est 4 c'est pour bloquer le Fousse et
8 provoqué aussi voilà pourquoi Maxime
la jouer d'ailleurs tu vois ici que sur
qu'on donne la dame et en cas de prise
yoromatine qui n'est pas passé
bizarrement bizarrement
donc là
pour empêcher cavalier
en tout cas maxime a pas obtenu
grand-chose de l'ouverture je pense
pour l'instant
qui est thématique sauf pour libérer le
fou c'est 8 qui va souvent en baisser
alors là sur petit Roc Noir on aurait
une position extrêmement complexe avec
les rock opposé
le fou de Maxime serait braqué alors sur
le petit noir mais il y a eu ce B3 de
Maxime qui avance le point de percée au
niveau de son propre grand rock donc
c'est une position qui est complexe et
Kemer fidèle à son habitude à plutôt
jouer pour le fait d'appauvrir la taque
et le piquer la paire de fou
on aura encore les rencontres
c'est le coup que j'aurais joué aussi
l'idée en fait c'est d'ouvrir les
cadeaux
la jauge on voit qu'elle aime pas trop
ça mais c'est le coup que j'aurais joué
aussi en blitz parce que ça m'a l'air
d'être
chaud là il faut répondre tu vois parce
que là il faut quand même être réactif
avec les noirs
et si tu commences à m'embêter avec un
là je vais faire F6 tu vois je veux
casser la diago ton fou mais je peux pas
encore parce qu'elle pue aussi donc il
faut que je fasse quelque chose donc ce
sera F5 si tu me joue dame G4 pour
gagner des tempos peut-être mais du coup
cinq ça fait plaisir ma case de 5 c'est
ça que je réussisse à bétonner je suis
pas sûr
ce que je fais F5 E5 quelque chose comme
ça j'ai laissé aussi coup de réserve
je pense qu'on est mal parti
j'ai joué le coup de caméra
[Rires]
c'est une partie c'est une partie tout
contre Kevin alors on est mal parti
il y a du courage du Tour H4 G4 il peut
aussi arriver
de te voir
et du coup
maxime a changé de coach n'est-ce pas
alors coach un grand mot Etienne c'est
un second temps un conseiller et on nous
demandait des nouvelles de sa nouvelle
équipe mais ça n'a pas filtré
attention on sera bientôt j'imagine bien
sûr on sera bientôt peut-être que c'est
pas encore tout à fait
clair cette histoire même pour lui je
pense
l'attaque de Maxime et surtout
prends aussi si je bouffe là t'as fous
c'est huit qui me fait un petit clouage
sur la dame E5 ok bon là on a envie
d'envoyer là on a envie d'envoyer la
sauce
mettre en face du fou ça m'a l'air assez
bizarre après il voulait empêcher
fousser vite il vous l'empêcher pour ça
qu'il a bougé la dame mais on voit que
la paire de fou commence à faire un peu
son effet à côté de noir
et puis là on va activer le foodcase
blanche maintenant bien sûr le prochain
coup c'est l'activation du foot case
blanche on se demande un peu comment
Maxime va réussir à attaquer voilà il a
trouvé
[Musique]
mais c'est pas la bonne nouvelle quand
même pour pour Maxime
entre les parties qu'on a vu hier la
partie contre maximienne ou de la
dominer quand même et celle-là tu
dégages une impression de facilité
tu as l'impression que Maxime quand même
il a il a enfin quoi gamer il a fait des
énormes progrès en fait ces derniers
temps
après Maxime je trouve qu'il a une très
bonne gestion du temps dans cette partie
et au-delà de ça n'oubliez pas que la
pression à une importance à une
incidence puisque là on voit que Kemer
et c'est quand même de calmer le jeu
d'échanger les dames
on a Jules aussi un ennemi sur deux
et on a ce mazet en difficulté à 0 sur 2
qui a eu des appareils énormes puisqu'il
va jouer chez Paris 9 et 20 Rasmus deux
joueurs à plus de 26 50 en temps normal
presque 27 donc du coup c'était très dur
et il y a même une très très belle
partie de semaine Rasmus dans la ronde 2
que vous pouvez regarder si vous avez
envie de voir des parties sur le thème
du sacrifice positionnel
de qualité d'ailleurs je l'ai pas
précisé voilà avantage à Kemer pourquoi
parce que il a le fou contre le cavalier
heureusement le cavalier de Maxime est
joliment placé mais sur le long terme ça
reste quand même difficile c'est
position là
néanmoins ça tient tout à fait ça va pas
être facile pour Kemer de passer et il a
20 secondes contre 40
et voyez là dessus
qui permet d'empêcher tout ça peut-être
un jour on verra peut-être arriver un
taux F4
il a la colonne il a la colonne F et que
Maxime il peut pas jouer G4 à cause de
tout ref-4 et du coup il y a le pion H1
qui traîne toujours donc maximum de coup
si vous voulez il est beaucoup plus
restreint il joue que dans son camp il
fait il peut pas faire de menaces alors
que moi j'ai des fouaf 7 je peux
m'amuser ici
Maxime il va essayer de profiter du
temps il va essayer d'avoir peut-être
que Kemer ça faille c'est vraiment le
jeu le jeu ultra rapide et d'ailleurs
pourquoi la jauge s'excite cavalier
aussi s'oublier peut-être
mais on revient on prend une fois on
revient
ok prends tu reviens tu peux pas tu peux
pas tout garder presque
une super partie mais on voit pourquoi
Maxime et champion du monde de blissant
titre il joue quand même extrêmement
vite et pose des petits problèmes
tactiques c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas
eu la caméra sur Vincent Kemer qui
devait être bien dégoûté il avait fait
une jolie partie mais Maxime l'a eu dans
les complications c'était juste non
après après
tu as bon c'est le bled gamer ça fait
combien de temps qu'il joue avec 10
secondes à la pendule tu vois toute la
partie il a joué avec avec très peu de
temps et tu finis par craquer et c'est
tu vois Maxime il était mal mais au
final bah écoute tu lui mets la pression
et puis tu finis par craquer quoi
mais c'est dommage pour pour cameram
mais en tout cas c'est une très très
bonne nouvelle pour le français Maxime
qui qui du coup remonte avec deux et
demi sur trois dans ce tournoi on a on a
4 scène qui a gagné Naka qui a gagné Guy
qui a gagné tout le favori qui gagne
moins c'est encore assez normal
et on a aussi on a aussi du coup pranave
V qui vient de battre un imam Imane qui
avait 2 sur 2 1 qui aurait pu affronter
un aka ou un quart de scène dans cette
4e range roi du monde ce sera pas pour
maintenant après après c'est clair que
que bon je pense trouver
une ronde je pense que c'est vrai en
juin des deux peut-être un moment donné
mais voilà il y en avait des questions
sur qu'est-ce qui se passe si ce jouet
moi c'est rien on a carvana qui joue ici
contre Bill gone shumuya il reste encore
quelques parties effectivement et
Fabiano Caruana va gagner avec cette
pion passé et ouais
hier du coup c'est 45 qui qui s'imposait
dans le championnat du monde de deux
rapides et bien sûr là oui les la
tactique aux échecs c'est tellement
important c'est hyper important un taxi
et ben surtout en blé ça vous voyez que
ça va se jouer bon à part Carson et bon
beaucoup d'autres joueurs à ce niveau-là
qui arrivent à faire des master class
positionnels en blitz c'est vrai que à
notre niveau à nous quasiment tous les
Blitz se jouent sur son tactique c'est
lui qui fait la remarqueries qui perd
quoi en gros c'est ça donc lactique
c'est important
- 30 secondes c'est dur quoi c'est
beaucoup trop dur en fait on n'a pas
enfin même Carcassonne en fait il fait
des gaffes on a vu hier contre contre
qui arrive
c'est il me fout j'ai un qui peut
arriver aussi c'est très compliqué pour
pour les blancs donc Abdou qui qui gagne
sa partie
2500 mais bon en blitz ça va très vite
mais c'est vrai que il va falloir vite
se refaire
gagné parce qu'on en a mis dans le chat
qui a gagné avec les Noirs
il aime ça je vais vous mettre si vous
voulez le côté le côté noir il a joué
son dragon accéléré à l'ancienne qu'il
adore tant qu'il chérit
incroyable
enfin c'est le seul piège qui existe
dans cette position c'est un peu
enfantin c'est un piège qui est qui est
très connu ça dans le dragon avec la
bassin très intéressant d'ailleurs oui
et à ce niveau là mettre final 2400 et
l'autre ça m'a l'air assez incroyable de
se prendre cavaler prend les cartes
quand même
tout ça bien sûr Sébastien le connaît
donc il a pas besoin de immunité pour la
dame noire
voilà
comme
en mode blanc
pourquoi il y a pas de ça je joue pas
parce que les joueurs ne veulent pas
jouer on va pas se mentir il y aurait
des problèmes de triche intelligente
c'est à dire que les joueurs n'auraient
pas besoin de tricher à chaque coup mais
il tricherait intelligemment on va dire
en utilisant l'ordi à certains coups
donc ce serait même pas réalisable
Franky malheureusement je sais que c'est
un spectre un peu négatif de ma part
mais honnêtement c'est la grande
problématique non mais en fait je veux
un tournoi pour moi le feed c'est quand
même des parties
sur un voyage chéquier exactement
jouer sur internet comme ça c'est ouvert
à tout à trop de trucs bizarres quoi
juste pour pour le thème là on a un
thème de parapluie sur la position
finale bon on peut imaginer normalement
le classique du parapluie c'est qu'il y
a même pas de pions 3 noirs parce
qu'avec les deux pions évidemment c'est
trop facile à gagner et même si dans
cette position il n'y avait pas le pion
E3 des Noirs bah le pion G5 en fait des
blancs il sert de cache pour pas se
prendre les échecs on appelle ça le coup
du parapluie il y a quelques finales
comme ça qui qui sont assez connus
parapluie par rapport aux échecs
intempestifs de la tour en tout cas
c'est un thème bien connu et on va se
cacher derrière l'option était pas là
bon là avec deux pions ça va quand même
gagner mais par exemple s'il y a pas le
pion E3 et qui a pas de plongée bah là
j'ai quand même plein d'échecs et c'est
pas si sûr que tu vas la gagner
ouais mais en fait juste les parties
lentes sur Internet c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué à mettre en place donc
j'ai eu une discussion avec l'autre jour
c'était hyper intéressant il me parlait
d'un tournoi éventuellement
hybrides avec des arbitres tout ça comme
il y avait eu d'ailleurs il y avait eu à
la comment s'appelle la métropole tu
vois ça éventuellement si en fait tu
joues sur internet en partie lente etc
mais que tu as un arabitre bah écoute
éventuellement c'est un truc qui qui est
qui est qui est intéressant quoi par
contre là tu es chez toi tout seul ta
personne qui te regarde enfin excuse-moi
mais c'est trop tentant de regarder
l'ordinateur tu vois les mecs tu vas
jouer enfin tu vois ça va être du
n'importe quoi et moi perso j'ai pas
envie de mettre mes hélophytes
sur un tournoi ou en fait il va y avoir
la triche de partout quoi ouais bien sûr
c'est horrible déjà moi je participais
souvent le week-end là je t'avais déjà
dit au
compétition c'est la team France
et dès que je joue en rapide je me suis
pris beaucoup de tricheurs
malheureusement donc ça me fait de jouer
avec des cadences qui sont en 10 minutes
sur cheesecom bah tu prends le tricheur
en fait bien sûr j'ai arrêté moi des
tournois comme ça même en 3-0 je suis
pas de France de Blitz par internet je
sais très bien qu'il y a eu de la triche
etc et c'est pénible hyper pénible
de l'argent en jeu c'est si c'est pas
bien fait la surveillance c'est hyper
galère encore chasse comme c'est c'est
vraiment plutôt bien pour la détection
de la triche mais il y a d'autres sites
Internet ou c'est pas terrible moi tu
vois moi cet endroit là j'en ai fait
aucun sur Internet parce que ça
m'intéressait pas en fait je vois que
c'est toujours la même chose donc enfin
voilà moi je suis pas rentré dans ce
truc là
mais mais c'est vrai que tu vois enfin
moi en plus ces événements je te disais
les événements que de team France je les
stream et je les stream et en fait juste
c'est pas cool quoi je prendrai un jour
à personne c'est hyper pénible en plus
tu sens que tu joues qui est bien
au-dessus en fait tu as zéro chance et
tu le sais très bien
et le pire ces questions voilà en fait
et ben tu joues en aller-retour
la première partie le mec j'ai vu je le
sais qu'il a triché contre moi et que du
coup j'ai une revanche à faire
obligatoire
et que voilà et en plus comme j'avais un
vélo tu sais qui était pas encore très
stable en rapide
100 points en tout tu vois je m'en fous
un peu des autres c'est comme mais par
principe en fait juste je supporte pas
sur les choses donc
si en rapide c'est c'est aussi compliqué
à jouer alors il m'arrive même pas en
partie lente avec des avec des prix avec
des hellofides vous imaginez vous allez
avoir des des joueurs à 1300 qui vont
arriver à 2002 enfin
juste c'est juste non c'est juste pas
possible et je sais que le format
hybride va la Ligue de Bretagne je crois
que c'est une ligue pilote pour ce
projet là tu vois ils vont commencer à
mettre des compétitions en place
après tout le monde n'est pas favorable
parce qu'il y en a qui disent que ça
casse le jeu il y en a qui a moins
l'aspect Internet le l'aspect 2D tu vois
il y a tout aspect là c'est très très
difficile
de faire changer les mentalités et
au-delà est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
ou non des fois on perçoit pas les
choses mais en tout cas ça mérite ça
mérite d'être testé et on verra ensuite
si ce projet peut aller plus loin bon en
tout cas moi je pense c'est une bonne
idée j'en ai parlé longuement avec avec
Charlie et il y a des raisons pour et
contre tu vois par exemple moi je vois
pas un
petit vieux qui n'a jamais touché un
ordinateur de sa vie allait faire une
compétition hybride avec l'ordinateur
c'est ça tu vois comme par exemple c'est
vrai qu'il y a des joueurs qui des fois
peuvent pas se déplacer
ou même tu vois faire des Interclubs
mondiaux enfin tu vois ça c'est
intéressant il y a des il y a des trucs
intéressants mais d'un autre côté
tu vois quand tu as des weekends où il
faut aller à l'autre bout de la France
moi je me souviens que à l'époque on
joue en N1 bien sûr il y avait il y
avait moi j'habitais à Nice et je suis
déjà à Belfort sur le week-end donc le
samedi matin tu pars
plus à Belfort tu as toujours samedi tu
joues dimanche tu rentres dans la nuit
et tu travailles le lendemain lundi
matin enfin juste c'est c'était abusé
quoi et je vois très bien j'ai fait ça
aussi je comprends tout à fait ce que tu
ce que tu dis tout c'est horrible il y a
qui nous dit que ton son est un tout
petit peu faible alors je vais leur
monter un peu mais tout à l'heure
j'avais un problème déco apparemment
donc où je l'avais un peu baissé par
rapport
à un petit peu voilà je la remonté
j'espère que ça va mieux
mais parce que j'ai pas forcément le
même retour son que vous dans le stream
donc moi j'entends très bien souffle
malheureusement alors du coup oui
n'est pas là c'est très dommage on
aurait bien aimé le suivre c'est un
joueur qui clairement aurait pu
challenger Carlson dans les deux
compétitions
mais bon on a pas eu de d'explication on
imagine qu'il n'est pas pro Blitz rapide
en ce moment il veut se concentrer sur
sur l'entraînement de partie lente je
pense il a fait un petit title pour se
refaire et c'est tout voilà c'est ça et
sinon la partie commence ben bientôt
alors j'ai pas les horaires enfin j'ai
les horaires mais si on suit les
horaires la partie elle devrait déjà
avoir commencé
normalement chaque demi-heure et ben en
même parti à 11h30 on a à peu près dans
le timing je pense Stéphane ça va encore
ouais ouais il y a un petit peu de
retard mais ça va donc
on va avoir un peu comment ça commence à
comment ça continue comme ça dans tous
les cas oui la partie va commencer là
vous voyez la salle de jeux je peux vous
montrer si vous voulez même la salle un
peu en plus grand vous ne verrez plus
mais du coup vous verrez la salle un peu
un peu plus grande ça peut être sympa
aussi
mais en fait il y a un peu de retard
love par rapport à l'organisation par
rapport au fait de mettre des
appariements des fois il y a des parties
qui peuvent durer plus longtemps que
prévu enfin il y a plein de choses qui
sont
qui a pas de raison en fait si tu veux
un attroupement au fond de la salle on
n'est pas encore le cas donc là on voit
au fond de la salle on voit on voit
Sébastien masser que sa belle veste
je pense qu'avec mvl au fond à droite là
dans le coin on voit je crois que c'est
Sébastien Mazet et mvl quelle vue
stouffe et tu as vu c'est vrai qu'on
avait vu passer avec cette veste là
depuis hier donc enfin depuis le début
des rapides donc du coup je l'ai reconnu
avec sa veste après peut-être que c'est
pas lui mais je pense que c'est lui
celui à la démarche à la démarche il y
en a pas deux des loustiques comme ça
d'ailleurs on aurait bien aimé qu'ils se
qui se mettent en capitaine c'est
nouvelle tenue mais je crois que dress
code ne permet pas à cela c'est un peu
dommage j'allais au Kazakhstan et puis
de se faire sortir parce que tu as mis
la tenue du capitaine
salut à toi salut filou ouais à 6h de
voiture pour 4h30 ah oui c'est ça ça
devient
ça devient long tout ça mais après bon
maintenant il y a beaucoup moins de de
il y a eu il y a plus de groupes qui
sont prévus en N1 elle sait que par mois
quand je quand je me déplace et ben je
faisais genre un maximum Nice
Montpellier quoi ça fait 4 heures il y a
plus
des échecs tout simplement dès que dès
que vous jouez et plus vous jouez à bon
niveau pire c'est en fait voilà oui
parce que c'est du vécu aussi
quand vous êtes un peu débutant ou
joueur plus modeste vous avez des
départementales les régionales et dès
que vous commencez à jouer en au moins
en M la finale 2 National 1 là vous
commencez à faire des gros déplacements
mais encore maintenant aujourd'hui de
toute façon sont un peu moins moins
il me semble moins grand qu'à l'époque
en fait tout j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
un litige parce qu'il y a quand même un
attroupement tu vois de personnes d'un
échiquier en fait j'avais pas de monde
compris cela c'est une partie qui est en
cours
c'est pas laquelle est en cours je crois
que c'est la seule qui pour moi le
résultat n'est pas terminé c'est pour ça
qu'en fait il y a
tout mangé
et malheureusement ben j'en sais pas
plus hein j'ai pas de caméra je vais
voir
qui est revenue
c'est à moitié étonnant parce que je
Bava et c'est un joueur qui aime je peux
dire qui aime bien les conflits mais
c'est un joueur
où était-il alors on ne sait pas ce qui
s'est passé
je vais avoir si on peut vouloir trouver
la partie
peut-être que on va trouver
la raison pour laquelle
il y a eu ce petit conflit on a non
c'est pas le baval c'est pas nous
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici je vois
pas qu'il y a des noirs
qu'est-ce qui aurait pu se passer
dans la position est-ce qu'il y aura une
sorte de répétition ça semble très
étonnant
en plus
[Musique]
et ce qui se met est-ce qu'il a enlevé
sa chemise peut-être dans notre chat il
y a peut-être des idées comme ça et du
coup il n'a pas respecté le dress code
en faisant ça non je sais pas du tout
je ne sais pas après on aura peut-être
des explications plus tard souvent on a
des petites
des petits compte-rendus un peu de
cheeseccom ou le site de la fille de
tout ça sur sur Facebook des fois on
voit un petit peu ce qui s'est passé des
conflits tout ça
[Musique]
des joueurs de l'équipe de Norvège et
qui olympique avec Carlson
moi vraiment il y a rien eu un gamin
effectivement il y avait pas l'échiquier
mais on a on n'a pas décrypté il y avait
une pièce de plus nette si vous voulez
sur l'échiquet de bas à gauche au bavard
et c'est ce qui
conduit à notre étonnement d'autant plus
que je Bava n'avait pas l'air content du
tout de son sort
oui il a pas envie de il a pas envie de
faire nul
ça fait bien rigoler les spectateurs et
les spectateurs sont tous grands Mac
quasiment ça peut être même un piège à
jouer je vois pas ce que ça peut être il
a pas touché
[Musique]
là il y a marqué nul sur sur
rapidement la position finale de base au
Bava pour vous expliquer notre
étonnement et je garde de vous montrer
ça
[Musique]
je te laisse les données je vais voir si
je vois ouais il a bien fini
pour voir il a bien fait nulle
pour l'instant en tout cas du coup on a
un adlim VL cool c'est bien c'est un bon
appareil man je trouve
donc on a eu si ça s'appariment là hier
lors de la lors du rapide ou MV laver
les blancs et abattu abattu ah non
pardon non non
c'est un très bon blixeur Adly mais il
est quand même moins fort que que Bassem
ça c'est ça c'est clair et net
Jules il a perdu malheureusement donc il
a un et demi et il va jouer encore un
ouzbek vakidoff Jacques conjuguer 2005
07 qui lui a plus de 1600 en l'an aussi
dur hein Game qui a 2600 hello et donc
il a tout à fait moyen de le battre ok
aucun souci là-dessus mais hier en fait
si tu veux hier en fait il avait 2006
quasiment 200600 hello Sébastien avec
son éloigner rapide donc il veut des
joueurs plus modestes souvent 1400
maintenant qui lui il a 2430 là en blitz
Sébastien c'est lui qui va jouer contre
2006 tout le temps quoi
donc il a un tournoi très difficile en
vue tout à fait là c'est dur et
donc Karlsen Thomas showski Nakamura
Sarine tiens c'est marrant
et on a appstrov qui tout
on a aussi guirishimanov Douda Pranav le
petit indien là et on a un grand maître
à 2005 contre contre ma médias
et demi il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choc
aussi il y a 20 forest kerwana
c'est très très chaud donc voir un peu
ce qui va se passer dans cette ronde
en tout cas c'est moi j'aime beaucoup
les Blitz ça va très très vite
exactement alors du coup
table 9 malheureusement pas les caméras
encore une fois sur sur Maxime mais on
va quand même le suivre
donc mise à jour 2 et demi sur trois
pour mvl Jules un et demi sur trois et
Seb 1 sur 3 voilà les scores de no
frenchies et on te posait la question on
se trouve de ton pseudo comment est né
le pseudo-stouf ah c'est une longue
histoire
bah stuff c'est comme staff en gros et
en fait quand j'étais quand j'étais tout
petit et bah master n'arrivait pas à
prononcer mon prénom et du coup elle
m'appelait elle m'appelait tout
et c'est parti de là et du coup il y a
beaucoup de monde qui m'appelle stouf
même avant même que je me crée mon
compte de twitch tout ça avant tout ça
et Ben et ben il y avait beaucoup d'amis
proches même dans ma famille aussi mon
frère et ma sœur tout le monde m'appelle
stouf voilà donc en fait c'est très
simple il y a pas bonne question en tout
cas une très belle réponse on a bien
aimé
mais voilà c'est simple
c'est simple
merci galinda pour pour les précisions
pour Philou Garou c'est nickel
ouais 12 à 12 joueurs à trois sur trois
donc franchement
c'est les gros joueurs là qui sont à
trois sur trois là ils sont plus que 12
ouais à 3 sur 3 et là il y a que des
monstres que des monstres genre habitué
du circuit bon il y a deux jours qu'on a
un peu moins c'est prana avait lasavik
donc pranave moi je le connais bien
c'est un indien qui qui a à peu près 15
16 ans qui vient de passer grand maître
et qui a ouais sur James com il a 3000
ans et la zavik pareil c'est le genre
aussi qui avait une finale hier c'est la
finale tour cavalier contre tour qui a
joué pendant je sais pas combien de
temps
contre don chenko
c'est lui qui est aussi à plus de 3000
sur Télécom donc c'est vraiment des de
très forts à mettre qui ont trois sortes
qui ont 330 aussi
[Musique]
[Rires]
et très très bon très très bon et une
histoire un peu similaire avec
une grande tente qui m'avait appelé kiwi
et mes frères avaient bien bien kiffé et
c'est vrai que des fois j'ai le droit un
kiwi de temps en temps où j'aurais pu
faire kiwicher
aussi
pour reprendre l'idée de stouf mais
mais non j'ai choisi Pro Évolution et
chaque parce qu'on jouait beaucoup après
Évolution Soccer à la base avec mes
frères donc révolution soccer c'est un
jeu de foot sur console à la base comme
ça qui est né le nom à l'époque même si
FIFA a réussi à comment dirais-je
détrôner un petit peu pour Évolution
Soccer qui à l'époque était très très
joué
et
concernant la question je sais plus
c'est ma coccy je crois que tu demandais
est-ce que les packs que je fais là sur
la plateforme vidéo sont adaptés si on a
1200 hello oui c'est un peu c'est à
partir de ce niveau là que ça a été fait
c'est bah vous êtes plus que débutant ça
fait un petit moment que vous jouez et
du coup je visais la tranche 1200 à 2000
à peu près avec des packs niveau
amateurs et des packs niveau avancés
aussi des fois il y aura même des suites
d'impact niveau amateur avec des packs
niveau avancés le canevas des des packs
est fait maintenant il y a plus qu'à les
faire pour faire grandir tout ça donc on
vous mettra des petites cubes de nos
chaînes des petites choses quand on fera
peut-être des petites pauses mais là ça
va reprendre assez vite qu'on mettra ça
tout à l'heure si vous avez envie
d'aller voir la chaîne de stouf chaîne
Youtube chaîne twitch pareil pour moi
chaîne chaîne Youtube chaîne twitch on
vous donnera les liens et plateformes de
cours en ligne ça c'est la nouveauté
récente voilà voilà et je pense que ça
va pas tarder les joueurs sont en place
tout
je mets des scores juste
l'histoire
et donc on a toujours pas de caméra
malheureusement sur sur Maxime et c'est
et c'est un problème
enfin c'est un problème smartphone c'est
dommage on aurait bien aimé avoir
une caméra
sur Maxime
on n'a pas du coup avoir un peu ce qui
se passe en tout cas on va suivre quand
même
les caméras d'à côté tu vois on voit
Sarine et on a l'arrivée des poids
lourds maintenant si tu veux
farine on le connaît bien au niveau des
blits je vous ai dit partenaire de club
il est où ton petit d'ailleurs dans le
classement je vais le chercher je sais
pas mais il me semble que je l'ai pas vu
[Musique]
3 V4 ou son système
en fait c'est un système suisse
Edelweiss
dans le sens en fait tu as
imaginons tu as 20 joueurs et ben tu
coupes en deux ça fait 10 10 et le
premier de chaque groupe jouant ensemble
en fait ça fait un 11 de 12 etc et c'est
que ça marche ça marche à peu près a
priori aussi l'histoire des couleurs il
faut qu'on ait le même nombre de fois
les blancs et les Noirs donc ça dépend
un peu mais après au niveau des
apparements c'est un peu comment ça se
fait et à chaque rond demain ça se
rétrécit et du coup à la fin bah les
joueurs
fallait plus fort finisse par jour
ensemble normalement
voilà en gros c'est ça ça marche comme
ça
arbitre mais il a choisi entraîneur il
nous l'a dit hier
j'ai fait mes trucs mais surtout surtout
pour c'était à l'époque pour mon club
pour pouvoir inviter également que je
faisais dans mon club mais maintenant
écoute ça m'intéressait pas puisque ça
je préfère
bien sûr on a tous pareils et j'ai vu un
appareillement hyper rigolo tout
c'est à un et demi un demi tu as le choc
Badour je Bava contre regaizy pour se
refaire en bas à dos avec sa position
archi gagnante il joue il joue à ryoun
et c'est pas facile on essaie de
finissent pas après c'est parti après
les deux c'est quand même très très fort
donc il peut se passer n'importe quoi
mais bon il faut qu'il gagne quand même
c'est cool
Franky j'ai regardé rapidement si
j'avais reçu un mail de ta part donc la
réponse est non alors attention j'ai pas
mal d'adresses email je les ai pas
toutes checker rapidement mais si c'est
directement mail de la plateforme c'est
pas moi qui le gère en direct
tu as vu les spams
non j'ai pas regardé
donc il faut faudrait que tu me dises
sur quelle adresse mail tu l'as envoyé
et là je pourrais te répondre
jamais les éléments tu me rediras
et du coup c'est là qu'on a eu cette
prépa monstrueuse hier est-ce que tu
penses sauf qu'il a regardé la partie de
du bois c'était quasiment donc
d'abord
empêché de roquer je crois non
donc en fait
d'abord avant cavalier E5
des particules le plus fait vibrer
c'était Charlie dans notre chat qui nous
avait proposé d'aller la voir c'était
bien vu de sa part et là du coup à mon
avis qui qui tank au cinquième coup
c'est bizarre je sais pas si on a un
problème de connexion ou c'est ou c'est
juste ça ah non ok on a eu connexion et
là c'est aller très très long attends on
va revenir un petit peu rapidement là
non il y a pas de souci donc Francky
c'est bien ça a pas envoyé directement
mail de la plateforme c'est pas moi qui
le gère et surtout cela c'est les
vacances enfin c'est les vacances de
Noël tu vois donc c'est un peu moins
réactif ce qu'on me fait suivre si les
gens demandent quelque chose en direct
qui me concerne parce que des fois si tu
veux comme c'est aussi l'adresse du mail
de support
waouh il y a grosse
qualité pour aller manger la tour en
face là haut donc j'envoie votre
structure mais je peux souvent faire du
H4 pour venir ouvrir un petit aussi le
roi blanc qui est plutôt bien un des
quatre moi j'aime beaucoup les Noirs ici
c'est une position très dynamique et
peut-être dame dessin qui est
intéressant pour
replacer un plat d'âme centraliser
j'attaque des cinq à deux je lui donne
un exemple qui peut arriver j'ai dû H4
ouais c'est hyper intéressant la
position
on a fait des paris le petit pouce en
bois alors on va te raconter rapidement
Kevin
là on a mis cinq écheliers enfin 5
pardon 5
premiers voilà top 5 top 5 je suis Kevin
ce serait Carson Naka nepo do dam VL
et chez moi ça serait 45 n'est pas mvl
occasion voilà donc rigolo c'est que
d'habitude on se base bien avec tout
fait hier on a trouvé carlstène champion
bon donc on l'avait pas compté et après
on a proposé pour stuff ergasing
et en fait personne n'est rentré dans ce
Top 4 hier qu'on aura rapide donc on
s'est quitté bons amis ce qui est rare
j'étais une place avec au départage 5e
donc ça c'est pas joué à grand chose
pour moi j'aurais pu j'aurais pu
vraiment qu'un peu de réussite
joueur ont beaucoup mieux joué que que
ceux que j'avais pronostiqué très
clairement il y avait un écart après si
on est encore plus joueur ce qu'on
pourrait faire c'est que
si jamais nos gens ne sont pas en top 5
et bon on les compare c'est à dire que
par exemple imaginons moi j'ai des potes
si aucun des deux top 5 et là on voit
celui qui arrivait le plus haut
mais on a quand même un problème dans ce
truc là c'est que par exemple on a
nakamépo après ouais ouais c'est
mais bon ok ça serait un autre Paris
qu'on aurait pu faire
alors
en même temps c'est de donner plus de
difficultés que d'habitude et c'est
plutôt aussi assez rigolo mais bon
alors on n'a pas le droit de croquer à
deux mais il va arranger ou apparemment
c'est pas du tout bon ouf
d'ailleurs j'ai fait la même dans ma
tête je me suis dame prend un de ces
jouets parce que il y avait faux-5 tu
sais stouf et en fait j'avais chaque
intermédiaire fousser un ça parle les
échecs intermédiaires
de Maxime j'ai pas le blâmer j'ai fait
la même
tu vois Maxime il a quand même deux buts
à la pendule
contre 40 secondes franchement c'est pas
excusable moi c'est une question la
bonne excuse c'est une question je te
posais la question ouais non mais tu
vois rien vu avec deux minutes tu as pas
le droit de faire une erreur comme ça à
ce niveau-là
[Musique]
de Maxime
mais il était très bien autant en fait
c'est ce que tu nous as expliqué hier
sauf il a voulu lui mettre la pression
au temps vous mettez la pression au
temps à quelqu'un vous pouvez vous
exposer après le musel bien
tu vois
c'est pas tarder à abandonner parce
qu'il est coincé il a bien joué à 10
c'est vraiment dommage ouais c'est
carton rouge comme lui dit Maxime c'est
complètement ça et c'est vraiment
dommage bon SIM qui avait une belle
pause si vous voulez c'est qu'un
[Musique]
point donné sur 21 ronde donc
c'est dommage
c'est des points perdus tu as pas besoin
après
10 minutes contre une en rapide
c'était parce que voilà
il joue BK
je pense ça sera insuffisant quand même
voilà
mais bon c'est pas si simple c'est
compliqué la vie c'est compliqué la vie
le joueur égyptien et il est important
[Musique]
le foot de gaz noire
GF2 incroyable
bon là c'est vraiment dû à la pression
Camille Maxime derrière et on va dire
que le jeu est égyptien qui avait si
bien joué jusque là était vraiment pas
tôt
c'était assez facile à gagner il avait
très bien tonifier au départ
et après il s'est mis la pression sans
doute tout fait il a complètement craqué
2600 hello c'est moi ça me choque
double carton rouge je crois dans ce
match
et peut-être que Maxime n'aurait pas
gagné de toute façon donc il a même
peut-être pas perdu de points puisque la
position était quand même assez solide
des deux côtés au moment où j'ai eu dame
prend à deux fautes au final si on peut
pas prendre à deux c'était égal bien
jouer Maxime comme ça il nous avait il
nous a fait des un petit rebondissements
incroyable
un carton rouge non mais en fait ok
Maxime bon mental mais bon Maxime je
pense qu'il a pas il a toujours le tempo
il a pas le choix c'est assez incroyable
même là par exemple j'aurais pas
forcément
bloqué là il y avait rien à jouer enfin
je veux dire un coup de fou tu vois
parce que du coup tu fais ça ça tu fais
ça enfin je sais pas en fait c'est
je comprends pas trop mais ok bon allez
c'est du bled c'est la pression il faut
contrôle le champion du monde elle en a
qu'à si vous voulez on va aller voir un
peu ce que nous fait notre petit
nakafon mais ça a l'air juste parce que
les tours de Naka sont très actives
donc Naka qui a qui a une qualité de
plus moi qui a pendant une tour de
pièces c'est ça mais
j'aurais dit avantage mais là tu fais il
est assis attention en gros assise qui
peuvent arriver ils ont plus de temps à
la pendule
c'est chaud c'est difficile à
spécialiste des petites entourloupes
mais c'est ma classe
qui empêche tout à 5 important bien joué
ça va être perdu après j'ai 4 pas trop
comment
ils vont jouer
dame d'un processus et il y a quand même
deux tours cavalier mais bon j'ai trop
de clients
je peux vous dire que il est présent il
est présent aujourd'hui 100% pour
démarrer
c'est un autre NACA c'est un autre
tournoi aujourd'hui
et ça va être abandon est-ce qu'on ira
pas prendre des nouvelles de nos joueurs
français maintenant on va aller voir ce
qui s'est passé chez les Français on a
quand même 45 à gagner Naka qui a gagné
you qui a battu Abdou on a guéri qui a
gagné
la zavie le jeune qui a battu ma média
du coup je vais voir un petit peu ce que
donne les Français dans cette ronde
certains favoris commencent déjà à se
démarquer
tel perf
[Rires]
en fait voilà quoi
donc il a joué une sorte de marozzi fait
tout avec
les Blancs regardez la prise de case
typique de Sébastien Mazet quand même
qui excelle dans les dans la stratégie
en général donc il donne le fou pour ce
cavalier qui est important qui permet de
venir après un dessin
c'est beau comme ce qu'il a fait
il a pris ce cadeau
et meilleures structure super partie
Sébastien Mazet bravo à lui hein
c'est vraiment un très très bon joueur
c'est sa force
[Musique]
catastrophique de la part du joueur
adverse
de la part de la part des Noirs
là il est pas bon parce que Sébastien
Mazet l'ami sous pression travaux et il
lui a tout bouffé
un lien alors j'ai un lien je vais vous
montrer je vais t'envoyer si vous voulez
le tien de chasse Resort
on regarde à chaque fois là-dessus moi
je regarde là-dessus ça va plus vite
comme ça au moins vous l'avez si vous la
regardez en même temps on a les
résultats en direct sur les
du coup je voulais voir Jules du coup
j'ai la perdue contre vakidof
je le vois pas mais c'est dur ça montre
que c'est dur pour tout le monde on vous
le dit mais c'est
avec les Blancs contre vacquidia dans un
joueur qui a 2006 aussi
c'est des joueurs qui ont qui ont un élo
un peu oui oui oui
on veut venir en F5 plus tard
c'est c'est standard il faut prendre un
6 de la part de Jules qui est bizarre
mais bon il a fait de voul pas voulu et
qui avait une pression sur le pion des
quatre qui a vous débarrasser un peu de
tout ça H3
il y a des il peut y avoir des problèmes
ah il y avait pas vu
ah oui pas du tout
il a le mauvais fou et
vous voyez même pour les champions c'est
dur
abandon là j'ai cavaliers
de sa partie complètement après c'est du
bled on peut vraiment rater une partie
qui a fait nul donc il y a trois sur
quatre trois sur quatre
parce que ça mentalement il faut avoir
des grosses ressources pour revenir mais
on l'a vu hier avec Maxime vous
enchaînez une de bonnes parties et c'est
reparti donc
[Musique]
c'est quand même le le numéro 1 et l'eau
au monde en blitz et donc
après Nakamura comme ça des fois il peut
être hyper en forme des fois il ne l'est
pas ça dépend un petit peu hier il a pas
du tout été il a mal joué mais c'est
quand même un des plus gros favoris du
tournoi avec
le top 2 pour moi en terme de puissance
franchement c'est les facile il est
facile dans cette cadence là on n'est
pas inquiet du tout pour lui pas du tout
donc on va voir un peu si j'ai des
résultats des appareils non des trucs
comme ça
il manque encore des non tout le monde a
fini
qui vont sortir dans quelques instants
donc on a on a eu zéro nul dans les dans
les les joueurs à 100% donc on a 47
Nakamura
[Musique]
on a Douda et on a laservic ça fait 6
joueurs à
4 sur 4 dont 5 sur 6 qui ont eu les
bancs
les pots je ne le vois même pas ah il a
il vient de perdre
il peut il peut revenir
donc Maxime qui a 2 et demi sur 4 qui
est encore encore là
bon 34 pardon qui est qui est qui est
encore là
Niman qui est encore perdu qui avait
deux sur deux et qui surtout à 204 du
coup
ah oui parce qu'on voit bien sûr les
plus forts en haut mais il y a quelques
désillusions j'ai vu des gros joueurs
green shook admis sur 4 par exemple pour
vous montrer la difficulté
du tournoi ce qui est finalement Jules
la nuit sur 4 c'est c'est pas c'est pas
terrible pour lui mais il y a d'autres
joueurs avec un hello encore supérieur
qui sont en difficulté et qui vont
essayer de revenir
du coup du coup tu vois j'ai aussi vu la
parie mais enfin le
combat
jobava irigazi qui se terminait avec une
victoire de herigasi
qui risque de tilt dans ce trou noir
parce qu'il appartient d'avant il a fait
match de nul on sait pas parce que c'est
passé mais il y a eu un il y a eu un
petit
un petit problème avec l'arbitrage je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et oui Hans il est un peu décevant sur
ces dernières journées effectivement en
tout cas il arrive pas à confirmer les
résultats après c'est du bide c'est
rapide c'est différent
et puis il faut dire aussi faut dire
aussi qu'avec tout ce qui se passe avec
avec Hans cinéma
bon tricher ou pas du tout se confirmer
là-dessus rien mais juste il y a quand
même une pression sur lui aussi hein
bien joué je trouve avec tout cette
pression d'ailleurs parce que tout le
monde
le tournoi enfin c'est quand même des
conditions particulières bien sûr et
jouer dans ces conditions là c'est quand
même extrêmement difficile est-ce que tu
peux nous mettre rapidement
s'il te plaît stouf la partie d'Abdou
santorov qu'on new Yorki donc
apparemment abandonné et on nous demande
pourquoi
OK
alors oui c'est un peu de changer du
jour du jour au lendemain c'est à dire
fera une prestation mi-finger en rapide
et être brillant ça existe
surtout pour des joueurs aussi forts
et il y a une menace de F4 en prime donc
sur wise4 voilà et sur dame F2 ce qu'il
faut faire quelque chose avec ce clouage
je suis obligé de le couper et il y a le
pion c'est aussi Qui est qui est hyper
important
voilà donc ça ça gagne et le pion sur la
dame F2 le pion C2 c'est un TGV on en
arrive pas l'arrêter
c'était peut-être le coup il a peut-être
abandonné dans une position il y avait
Dame des trois il était très bandelé
dans une position qui était qui était
gagnant
j'ai fait confiance bien sûr ce que je
regarde pas l'ordi tu vois et du coup
mais
il a raté un sauvetage en fait d'où ta
question peut-être
et là sur ces deux peut-être
il a oublié
ou alors il a perdu autant ce qui est
aussi ce qui est possible mais bon
avec la pression
difficile en pratique même s'il y avait
un sauvetage le sauvetage Dame des trois
bah c'est une sorte de contrat contre
point de tactique très jolie
apparemment donc dès que je les ai créé
où je voulais je vous le dis on a juste
le classement avec les six joueurs en
tête à quatre points voilà et pour
l'instant c'est you et guéri qu'on le
meilleur des partages qui doit être la
somme cumulée des points des adversaires
où on enlève le moins bon je pense que
c'est ça
ce qu'on appelle un bucol stronquet
j'ai toujours pas appariement mais on
peut essayer de deviner un peu
carte cell je pense bah je contrôle
parce que c'est le premier joueur
qu'il
avec qui il est compatible couleur
et par contre Nakamura moi je pense que
ça va être l'un contrecarcel
après ça va faire peut-être
[Musique]
un Douda blanc doubler les blancs contre
Naka
et ensuite un petit
laservic blanc contre gris
je dirais ça
je prends le risque
donc
[Musique]
guéri moi je dirais ça les Français je
sais pas encore il y a trop de monde en
fait il y a trop de monde à 2 et demi
donc je peux pas je peux pas vous dire
enfin il a trois pommes mvl mais à trois
points il y a les joueurs qui ont perdu
comme appsotorov il y a les joueurs qui
ont deux et demi qu'on fait nul et à
tous les joueurs qui ont deux qui ont
gagné donc ça fait énormément de gens à
trois malheureusement je peux pas faire
de calcul
mais à 3 sur 3 il y a des il y a
clairement des des calculs qui sont qui
sont à faire quoi mais deux demi trois
trois et demi il y a pas de genre à 3 et
demi s'il y en a 4 ans et demi
en tout cas il y a 21 ronde donc il y a
le temps de se refaire pour l'instant
les écarts sont pas significatifs on est
au tiers de la première journée
et à la fin de la journée on pourra déjà
dresser un bilan il y en a qui seront
quasiment foutus
mais on voit que nos favoris un Carlsen
enaka qu'on a cité
voilà dans nos pronostics ils sont ils
sont tout à fait présents Douda aussi
est présent mvl est présent et les
joueurs un peu en retrait c'est une
époque iriga easy mais rien de
significatif parce que on sait qu'ils
peuvent revenir ces joueurs en soufflent
il y a encore une fois il y a 21 parties
les joueurs sont capables de remontada
et puis je pense que dans l'entendre
comme ça
quasiment tous les joueurs vont avoir
des hauts et des bas tu peux pas à
chaque fois avoir enfin être on verra en
tout cas mais je vais 21 partie à ton
max donc même 45 peu en perdre une deux
voire trois d'affilés c'est c'est
possible
alors je vais voir si on a une caméra un
peu mieux je vois la caméra de la salle
il a parlé du système suisse c'est à
dire que tu coupes le tableau en deux
donc si tout le monde a 0 qui a 100
joueurs c'est très facile le 1 jour
qu'on ne le 51 et après faut comprendre
qu'il y aura des tu feras la même tu
mettras en place la logique pardon par
groupe de points c'est à dire que tous
ceux qui sont à 100% ils sont et c'est
ce que se trouve vient de faire il y a
pas si longtemps il y a il y a donc si
joueur et tu vas prendre le meilleur
classement qui va affronter le numéro 4
du groupe des 6 joueurs le 2 je vous
raconte le 5 et le 3 contre le 6 ça
c'est on va dire la logique basique
ensuite des fois pour harmoniser les
couleurs il y a bien sûr des petits des
petites des petites adaptations de ce
genre de choses voilà mais globalement
tu as compris je pense l'idée c'est ça
j'espère
après ça dépend parce que tu as les
couleurs tu peux pas tu peux doubler les
couleurs mais après il y a des il y a
des priorités par rapport aux couleurs
par rapport à plein de choses par
rapport à les lots enfin bref
générale il y a aussi un joueur qui a
deux et demi c'est toi tu as trois
points et ben bon généralement le jour à
deux et demi bah je contre le genre le
moins fort des trois
etc et il peut y avoir un nombre impairs
dans un groupe de joueurs dans un groupe
de points
voilà bien sûr c'est exactement ça
globalement il y a il y a le logiciel
papier en France mais il y a de il y a
je pense pas qu'il soit pas être
intéressant donc
tu as des
même à la main à l'époque je crois que
c'est c'est switch manager il me semble
le le programme de jet resold attention
si tu veux tu veux faire arbitre j'ai
l'impression que tu es en train de te
dévoiler là
arbitre aussi ok voilà parce que tu sais
qu'en fait en France n'a pas pu mais on
est le seul pays qui qui fait qui fait
un peu ça parce que dans notre pays en
fait tu vois nous ça serait on l'utilise
pas en France
[Musique]
on a fait des et alors dans d'autres
pays il va se résolve c'est en fait du
coup ils ont tous des programmes
différents il a plusieurs je connais
plus les noms mais il a plusieurs et du
coup ben après c'est un peu le même
genre tu vois à chaque fois c'est pas
très compliqué
mais voilà donc du coup
on peut dire qu'on est en avance sauf
si on peut dire que ça on peut dire que
ça va peut-être reprendre ce que je vois
les joueurs ils sont en train de
regarder les appareils
en rouge
et ce que j'ai la fait le sous-marin
en plus vu c'est vraiment un joueur qui
est capable de de faire
un très très bon état je peux faire du
monde donc après il peut faire le
sous-marin mais par hasard c'est à dire
qu'il commence à perdre après il gagne
tout et oui ça ça exactement mais c'est
pas du tout un truc prévu exactement
[Musique]
tout simplement parce que tu peux jouer
un jour plus fort en hello en ayant
perdu qui sera peut-être moins en forme
du coup mais du coup tous les joueurs se
valent à peu près à 26-27 dans les
groupes de points donc vos vaut mieux
pas essayer de Batman œuvre et puis on
l'a dit hein c'est des gros compétiteurs
et là il y a beaucoup moins en blitz
l'aspect on va on va faire des petites
nuls pour gérer le tournoi généralement
à part peut-être sur les trois dernières
rondes mais ils vont jouer à fond leur
partie et ils vont se [ __ ] sur la
tronche parce qu'ils adorent ça quoi ça
va reprendre ma rodiga là on voit les
joueurs qui sont en train de s'installer
donc je te dirai dans deux minutes allez
à 12h15 ça fait un petit Paris
alors Baron Rouge toi tu nous dis dans
d'autres façons top 5 il y aura Carl
scène Naka va chier dans quel ordre on
sait pas plus je leur Douda etc stage
Baron Rouge que tu as quasiment donné ma
liste de pronos Carlsen Naka n'est pas
celle de stouf est très proche avec 45
nepo Naka ml ouais
il est là l'année dernière tout a il a
fait au championnat du monde de rapides
et Blitz il a joué déjà le il a joué le
départage
en blitz donc j'ai plus compris
l'année dernière
il y avait vice champion vice champion
du monde en blitz et en rapide il était
il était je sais plus mais
4-5 donc tout ça c'est un bon client que
tu as choisi
moi je l'ai pas mis parce que
dernièrement il fait pas grand chose je
trouve
je l'ai pas choisi au hasard je
réfléchis toute la nuit tout à ma à ma
liste de pronos pour te faire quelque
chose au petit oignons alors du coup je
t'annonce que les apparemment sont
sortis et que j'ai eu tout faux c'est
zéro
bah écoute en fait il y a une image
qu'on est blanc et un et un galet noir
du coup
donc on a Douda du temps
ah non mais moi je l'ai fait ah oui non
moi j'ai compris pourquoi
il est il est là voilà donc c'est pour
ça que je me trompe en fait
sinon j'aurais peut-être des choses
différentes mais je sais pas ce que
j'aurais dit mais son bref je me trompe
pour vous expliquer et à baser son
calcul là-dessus alors que dans le
tournoi non c'est pas faire les
appareils
non c'est pas ça en fait si tu veux sur
sur
table 1
tout le temps d'accord alors que
Nakamura a plus de bruit et du coup dans
l'ordre des choses et ben Nakamura doit
être bleu en fait tu veux donc ça ça
change comme pas mal de choses il a
d'ailleurs l'étoile l'étoile parenthèse
qui doit être
tu vois donc
c'est les trois joueurs qui ont quatre
sur quatre à trois et demi on a Hansen
contre du rabahli
dangereux
aussi voilà et on a encore ragnès
Valentin qui un joueur qui a 2550 qui a
3 et demi aussi donc trois joueurs assez
quand même c'est vrai que trois joueurs
sont quand même bon blitzer mais assez
surpris
[Musique]
moi je suis d'accord avec toi
franchement est-ce qu'il va gagner notre
histoire
et après à trois bah il y a
[Musique]
parce que ils ont que un point de retard
et demi il y a rien de grave encore mais
il va falloir se correr ouais donc pour
le faire c'est tout hein oui oui après
il faut marquer des points quand même
mais après les joueurs sont quand même
tous capables de revenir
français on a Sébastien Mazet qui joue
contre zumbaf oui pas facile encore
je m'avait qui un joueur qui a 2620
après un feed donc donc bon écoute bah
c'est une partie qui se joue en tout cas
c'est c'est dur mais c'est pas
incroyable exact et jus de Moussa abonné
aux joueurs qui sont entre azéri ouzbek
et kazakh et joue que ça depuis le début
du tournage j'ai l'impression et sous
contrôle sous les Mali d'ailleurs il me
semble que sous les Mali c'est le joueur
qui a battu Jules hier dans la finale
avec un Pione
va avoir envie de prendre sa revanche
parce que la partie avait quand même été
dur à digérer je pense
il y a encore de très très bons joueurs
même dans des groupes de points et demi
on trouve
tout à l'heure mais il y a Valère au
ponce enfin vraiment d'être très très
fort grand maître
c'est c'est dur il y a guerka zéro et un
demi qu'on trouve vraiment des joueurs
beaucoup plus modestes et sinon je peux
vous dire que c'est c'est très très
chaud jusqu'à 1 et demi
on a des grands mètres à 2600 qui ont un
point comme game magaby que
qui est quand même un top jeu aussi qui
a quasiment 2016 fin 2006 60 par là donc
c'est dur c'est dur les joueurs allez ça
y est ils arrivent ils sont tous arrivés
pour les appareils j'ai vendu un peu du
rêve j'avais dit 12h15 sera 12h20 et je
peux vous dire que là ça va démarrer
incessamment
ça a commencé bientôt
tu vois les trois et demi sont il y a un
nombre impair de 3,5
donc il faut que le dernier des trois et
demi je joue le premier des trois
grossièrement c'est ça
tu apprends le joueur le moins fort mais
qui a qui correspond à ta couleur en
fait c'est assez compliqué alors on va
regarder unvel au niveau des échecs et
au niveau de la caméra bah ça sera
sûrement une autre une autre came
instaure tu confirmes alors attends
est-ce que je le mets en top 10 top 20
donc c'est pas du tout un débile
charnier femme moi je le je pense qu'il
peut faire un top 10 on a peut-être
oublié c'est peut-être ça et il a le
droit de faire mieux hein
je croyais pas enfin oublier dans nos
pronos quoi c'est à dire que voilà c'est
de toute façon
ça va se jouer à la à la à la forme
surtout tout ça donc
encore une fois on n'a pas la cam la cam
sur sur mvl c'est dommage
il va sûrement rentrer sur la caméra
donc on espère que
kick-up partie pour pour le voir
donc je vais vous mettre déjà la partie
de la partie mvl hop
mvl encombrement sur lui pour essayer de
faire d'obtenir son deuxième titre de
champion du monde d'affilée
noir une très bonne partie qui est assez
marrant chascom c'est que dans la
position finale on a un doute et on se
demande si abdosaurrav n'a pas perdu
dans une position n'a pas abandonné dans
une position gagnante ou perdue autant
dans une position gagnante si tu
regardes bien le chat
en entier mais la pollution finale et
ben l'ordinateur donne gros avantage
Abdou quand il abandonne donc c'est
assez bizarre
et mvl qui rejoue encore
la russe avec du coup le cavalier F4 F4
qu'il avait joué d'ailleurs
contre qui déjà c'était
[Musique]
un truc de mémoire je sais plus quoi
tu as raison tu as raison mais du coup
ça paraît être pas grand chose mais
c'est un petit peu pénible à gérer parce
que quand le pion arrive en D5 avec les
Noirs il se fait un peu maltraité
ça vaut le coup parce que c'est une
prépa un peu sans risque c'est à dire
qu'on joue juste aux échecs et on est
peinard
structure de françaises d'échange ou de
pétrole d'ailleurs mais avec les pièces
un peu mieux placées
la dame qui pourrait peut-être venir en
F3 le cavalier à chaque on a vu ce thème
là hier aussi le cavalier en D2 on peut
réussir à amener des pièces à la fête
exactement
après c'est les positions qui sont dures
à jouer pour les pour les deux joueurs
mais c'est quand même assez énorme sont
précis et qu'ils arrivent bien à jouer
de la pollution je pense c'est quand
même assez égal à cette position ça
symétrique tu vois comme française
échange
donc elle a un peu gênant pour le
développement
ou peut-être 5 d'abord pour échanger les
fous de caisse blanche
à la fois F5 d'abord il est échangé
qu'avait les 6 et changer un peu toutes
les pièces
mon ex sont bien les coups joués
mais je regarderai le début de partie
parce que du coup ça m'intéresse que tu
me dises que j'ai raté du coup des
choses parce qu'on va faire dans cette
cette partie j'ai pas analysé j'ai pas
vu ce qui se passait avant donc
peut-être que du coup il y a des choses
sympas qui se sont passées mais ok bien
sûr je mange un F4 j'ai pas cavalier
pour un F5 parce qu'il y aurait la prise
intermédiaire petit plus pour mvl mais
pas non plus grand chose est-ce qu'on
fait une expansion à l'aile d'arme cette
C4 D5 essaie de prendre plus d'espace
par là j'aime bien essayer de jouer sur
la case noire ce fou ne joue pas bien
pour l'instant c'est plus agréable c'est
plus agréable plus d'espace la position
est plus simple
et
ces quatre contrôles le centre pour le
jeu de
restrictions pour faire le blocus c'est
obligatoire je pense
que sur ces 6 B4 B5
encore un coup qui peut faire un peu
quand il veut je pense c'est 6
exactement
pour le cavalier noir donc H3 on va
améliorer la position
on va préparer la poussée je pense
latérale avec A4 B4
la jauge s'excite pas mais c'est dur à
jouer pour les noirs on n'a pas trop
d'idées sauf avec les Noirs en pratique
en pratique c'est difficile pour les
Noirs l'ordinateur lui s'excite jamais
parce que tout et lui il est pas du tout
il craint rien mais en tant que joie
c'est parti qui a une pression il y a
plus d'espace il y a plus de
possibilités côté blanc donc voilà nul
le
jusqu'à présent
l'année dernière la dernière ronde
et bien je veux qu'on entre comment il
s'appelle pour nepo et ils ont fait nul
sans jouer la dernière partie ce qui a
offert c'est qui a offert un épaule une
un départage contre apps de Rohff c'est
à dire qu'il a perdu mais n'a qu'à en
battant des pots pouvaient obtenir
une belle place un beau podium ou
peut-être même je pense pas qu'il
voulait les califes mais bon mais maca
avait même pas essayé de jouer l'iPhone
nul sans jouer donc du coup tu vois ça
n'a qu'à aller noire qu'on me guérit bon
écoute
ça me choque pas elle me dit riz blanc
il aurait pu jouer un peu mais bon
merci beaucoup à fortnite Le craignent
beaucoup à ce niveau là donc les gens
n'ont pas voulu jouer bon travail de mvl
en tout cas très positionnel l'améliore
crée des trous il a les bonnes pièces
est-ce que ça suffira pour gagner on ne
sait pas mais c'est vrai une position
vraiment une position à deux résultats
ou drague 9 et sur la défensive depuis
le départ et mvl tourne autour de sa
proie il faut juste qu'il cherche bien
sa pendule pour ne pas avoir de soucis
sur ce sujet
après un VL au niveau de la pendule tout
ça je me fais pas trop de soucis je sais
qu'il est rapide et qui il joue bien et
les tricky
donc même s'il est moins bien longtemps
je trouve pas trop le souffle là dessus
il faut prendre F5 qui a été envoyé ça
c'est ça c'est les coups qu'on aime bien
chez Maxime ou en fait
une pièce pour deux pions avec le renard
qui complètement ouvert donc on peut
imaginer une course
qui peut être joué
pour avoir mesdames G4 elle a quand même
très fort avec une menace de carénage
c'est le premier coup qu'on a envie de
regarder aussi pour regarder comment on
fait la SMAT là et je me fais aussi une
des découvertes sur la Dame des 7 comme
tu l'as dit il faut aussi ce qui couvre
un petit peu tout qui couvre les deux
diagonales
on a encore cavalier H6 pour continuer
avec nos pièces qui circulent quand même
librement
j'avais pas vu un pour être tout à fait
franc mais tu as pas de bol dans ta
combinette
[Musique]
grosse grosse pression je pense que
c'est quasiment perdu
enfin je vois pas encore le gains
la conversion il y a cavalier F5 qui
arrive
mvl a fait une partie positionnelle et
un moment sous la pression l'adversaire
a laissé une opportunité de sacrifier
bam direct ça fait mal et c'est tombé
c'est joli hein c'est joli mais même
Maxime qui a mangé un F5 quasiment tempo
quand même
il sent en fait parce que quand on joue
quand les premières 5 bien sûr il n'a
pas tout calculé Maxime mais il sent en
fait le film c'est important quand même
c'est ça qui est marrant même en jouant
très très vite c'est il avait anticipé
la situation mais c'est une intuition de
malade comme nous le disent tous
l'intuition c'est quand même quelque
chose de très important
et parce que ne croyez pas qu'il est
calcule jusqu'au matin en faisant en
faisant ça il est très fort mais là
c'est beaucoup trop compliqué donc
tout est bien
36 secondes contre 5 secondes bref aucun
risque il va il va être sérieux comme il
va la finir
tranquillou dame d'essai tu vas manger
des pions ici
je pense est-ce qu'on reste là dessus ou
est-ce qu'on va voir la partie à l'écran
Douda Carlsen une partie
mais peut-être finir là-dessus voir un
petit peu un petit peu
je pensais qu'elle terminait dans mes
chèques le pion on arrivera jamais à
Dame vous voyez donc on va envoyer notre
conseil on Adam 3 pions de plus en plus
de temps pour l'adversaire
et chaque échec
on va partir du coucher 45 j'ai vu Douda
faire une incroyable
il est un peu surpression avoir
l'impression d'Oda avec le cas noir là
car scène qui qui est quand même très
très fin en blitz même si on peut dire
que
[Musique]
ben c'est le seul hospit de chasse qui
rivalise avec avec NACA quoi après c'est
différent des parties comme ça de blés à
un match contre une personne
mais voilà je pense que grâce à n’est
quand même
favori dans toutes ses cadences H3 ça y
est les pions avancent et c'est terminé
c'est fini il se bat mais plus à rien
même si il est censé finir quatrième à
une battra pas Magnus là
karwana toujours aussi fort aussi il a
vraiment progressé maintenant et ça sera
un joueur sur qui faut compter il a
gagné une nouvelle fois
[Musique]
une qualité de plus une structure un peu
défavorable mais ça devrait suffire la
qualité du contrôler qui a 2137 hello
mais qui est un très très bon joueur de
de Blitz et Bullet
travailler
il veut garder la réserve de temps
aïe
je viens de faire une toile son cavalier
ce cavalier et je vois je trouve en
essayant de peut-être le dernier le
dernier
mais bon je pense que je mange la tour
quand même
[Musique]
je vais regarder sur sur les appareils
pour voir si ça a évolué comme ça vous
donnera le résultat
de cavaliers qui est qui est
complètement nul mais il a cavalé plus
contre cavalier le but des Noirs c'est
de réussir à vérifier le cavalier sur le
pion et ça fera nul direct donc là il y
a deux parce que le roi est quand même
bien placé le roi noir pour empêcher
l'avancée du pion blanc
mais il faut se méfier parce qu'il faut
pas se prendre la seule fourchette de
l'échiquier
qui qui empêche le plus avancer
et nièce mvl la 4 / 5 on va le on va le
changer je vais voir si les autres
Français ont terminé avant de changer le
score
mvl très facile dans dans la partie
précédente il avait un appareil manif
favorable mais il a confirmé que c'était
bien à faire un appareillement favorable
puisque je vois un bon grand maître mais
pas un grand maître de premier plan
cavalier à trois menaces une nouvelle
fois kfc2
et ça n'avance pas
j'ai le café nul
et
Seb qui a perdu
désolé pour toi pas de métal
qui est grand fan de darda
ils sont compatriotes c'est des joueurs
belges je me rappelais donc les Belges
il va avoir son petit yoga j'espère
qu'il a encore parmi nous notre petit
Charlie parce que là il va voir son vrai
son rêve se réaliser ça a pas durer
longtemps je pense
quand même
mais pas simple il y a un pion de plus
c'est plus doublé il y a des tours là
qui peut arriver
la partie
terminée surtout là je pense juste là et
dès que tu bouges ton roi je vais manger
3 je pense qu'il n'a pas voulu
ça fait nul
sur les joueurs belges attention il y a
quelques bons joueurs quand même quoi on
a Bart Michel
aussi je sais pas du tout ce qui devient
mais des fois les joueurs aussi
c'est toujours pareil c'est que
le joueur une fois qui sont plus
étudiants des fois certains choisissent
plutôt que faire proser chaque de
travailler comme cadre dirigeants ou
autre et du coup c'est plus c'est plus
la même chose oh là là on va avoir une
partie longue et on apprend
en fait elle est pas terminée
[Musique]
ne jouent plus à 70 il y a une prise
donc 72 donc ça doit être à peu près ça
effectivement sauf comme tu nous le dis
on a le droit à un roi tour fou en on a
le même joueur que tout à l'heure qui se
bat encore à l'écran la dernière partie
de ce tournoi
c'est incroyable
là le tofuge parle à l'air faire mal
donc c'est un joueur qui aime bien
sacrifier sa dame pour remarquer sauf
que là c'est vrai que c'est pas la même
j'ai trois pièces et en plus il y a
je voulais faire promo comme je trouve
prenez exemple
mais bon tout gagner en fait
c'est très sérieux aussi
c'est toujours dur de perdre une partie
pour les petits jeunes même si ce n'est
que une partie de Blitz c'est le choix
du monde il y a des attentes pour les
joueurs les plus modestes on va dire
c'est des maîtres ou petits grands
mètres ils ont envie de jouer devant
pour aller jouer des superstars et on
pouvait les scalper sur un blitz très
clairement
12 ans
[Musique]
il est là
peut-être ça pourrait être sympa je sais
pas si ça se mange son à jour
malheureusement chez moi j'ai pas du
tout classement à jour
je vais voir sur
sur du coup just result
et le classement je pense qu'il est à
jour ouais le classement est à jour donc
pour l'instant on a U47 à 5 points
guéri à 4h30 et à 4 points et à 4 points
on a on a une quinzaine de joueurs la
zavie
Douda dubaf pétrole Sarine ma média
on a
séparinovl tu as aimé mon petit
total
donc 15e mais bon égalité avec le 5ème
donc ça va on a martio Jean carwana
mamedia Rohff
embuscade
et voilà
le français on a Sébastien qui est 124e
avec
20224 juste devant jus de Moussard 127e
avec pareil deux sur quatre aussi mais
on voit que ton nom est très très fort
quand on voit que je bavarde il a un et
demi
quand tu vois que zigalko il a un point
enfin tu vois c'est c'est quand même
assez
assez incroyable tout ça c'est
extrêmement dur c'est extrêmement dur à
la fois on rêve de ce tournoi mais une
fois que tu y es bah il faut marquer des
points quoi ça peut vite tourner
cauchemar on va aussi que Hans Ziman il
a deux points il a commencé avec deux
sur deux il a trois défaites d'affilée
il va me perdre pranave Petrossian et
par avion
et on sait que il aime bien en plus
cette cadence là mais malgré tout ça
reste difficile
ça commence à être dur là il a perdu
shimanov Cup paradisé et là il va me
perdre contre Narayana c'est pas le
cadeau n'a rien quand on tient une part
de partie d'affilée
donc nepo qui a deux sur cinq aussi ouh
là là
mes potes 2 sur 5
extrêmement fort vous voyez donc
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe ce
qu'on a on a apparemment de l'Aronde 6
et du coup ça va donner un petit carcini
Yang ça vous l'avez deviné et
malheureusement Maxime vous tableau 6
quand ils veulent pas nous le mettre un
maximum ils veulent pas
aussi abordable et en l'occurrence c'est
le cas c'est ça donc Maxime qui vous
tape le 6 contre du rabahli avec les
Noirs donc bon du rabahus un genre qui a
quasiment 2006 donc pour Maxime c'est
quand même plutôt un bon apparemment il
évite des doudins il évite des sarines
il évite des joueurs plus dangereux
après bien sûr de Rabahi il est quand
même à 4 sur 5 hein c'est quand même pas
un touriste il faut il faut le battre
mais surtout un apparemment je trouve
qui peut lui sourire
ensuite on a table 2 on a Nakamura
karwana ça c'est un match intéressant à
suivre on a martyriozan contre guéri et
Dubois après A4 on a beaucoup de monde
et du coup là les parties à suivre ça va
être bien sûr mvl qui est en cours c'est
encore un pour le titre et et surtout
quinzaine de vent avec 5 sur 5 aussi
contre you
tout à fait l'un des gros matchs qui
vont arriver alors nos Français donc on
a Sébastien Mazet qui joue contre adilan
a dit bon c'est un joueur qui a pas
facile mais a dit bon c'est un joueur
qui a 5 à 10 bandes pour 2006 c'est un
2006 plus même c'est 26 50 à 10 ans
c'est vraiment un très très bon joueur
et Jules qui jouent un autre grand
maître aussi mais encore mettre un peu
plus modeste je pense sans Calpe plus
abordable
qui sont
[Musique]
calmes sans Calpe tu as 24 38 tes grands
maîtres tu joues avec les Noirs contre
une Moussa avec 2 sur 4 c'est quand même
pas facile non plus tu vois donc
des meilleurs blitzeurs au monde et il
est top 72 tranquille
sur sur 87
donc il est au fond de la salle
remis de la petite embrouille qu'il a eu
tout à l'heure bon c'est pas trop la
nature de l'embrouille mais quand même
c'était pas
ça a pas dû le mettre dans de bonnes
dispositions
en tout cas maintenant il est un petit
peu c'est un petit peu dur
pour lui dans cet endroit là
et je trouve pas ni même assise de
trouver il joue en 2464 table 55 à côté
de Mazet
à côté de Sébastien
et quand tu vois que des pommes
on peut très vite redescendre de son
nuage en Chine 2 3 défaites ou à
l'inverse remonter complètement avec
deux trois victoires il y a des joueurs
qui sont très forts on n'a pas parlé de
Richard rapporte voilà il est très très
fort et il est 24e table voilà pour
l'instant vidite aussi hier était revenu
André Keane il y a des joueurs qui sont
quand même en Busquets à trois points
qui peuvent très facilement revenir au
bénéfice de deux victoires de
consécutives voilà tu as pas aller vite
il y avait été très fort en rapide et
encore là par contre depuis tout à
l'heure on le voit bon là il est que
table 16 mais il joue des gros gros
joueurs depuis le départ
[Musique]
et il a fait il a battu deux jours à
2004 quand même donc effectivement
et tu vois je t'avais parlé aussi de
Android
le joueur internet qui est tout à fait
voilà donc il y a trois points sur 5 qui
a qui fait pas un très bon endroit pour
l'instant parce qu'il a perdu quand même
un 23003 mais il a quand même trois
points il a battu trois joueurs à peu
près 2400 hello et là il va avoir les
Noirs contre Max's de l'eau
ça dépend Cyril aussi des couleurs c'est
on vous a expliqué le système suisse
grossièrement mais surtout fallait
rajouter qu'il y avait aussi des des
correspondances couleurs à respecter
c'est exactement ça Edelweiss et il y a
déjà eu des confrontations entre
certains joueurs il faut en venir compte
aussi c'est pour ça que maintenant à une
certaine époque les arbitres devaient
tout faire à la main c'est extrêmement
dur pour eux aujourd'hui ils ont quand
même un confort c'est les logiciels
informatiques et les ordinateurs les
aident à mettre en place les appareils
et donc Magnus on a dit c'est le gros le
gros combat de l'Aronde 6 il va jouer
youngui joueur à plus de 2800 puisque
Naka jouera Fabiano carwana à la table 2
avec un demi point d'avance sur Fabiano
carwana on voit que maintenant dans
certains groupes quand les deux joueurs
se sont déjà joués par exemple les deux
quatre et demi c'était guéri et Nakamura
ils sont obligés d'aller voir chez les
quatre points
contre qui jouer tout simplement puisque
les les joueurs à 5 points n'hésitez pas
à affronté voilà les priorités qui peut
y avoir tout ça est un petit peu
complexe à expliquer mais quand vous
avez l'habitude d'arbitrer d'utiliser
l'ordinateur pour les appareils tout ça
devient très compréhensible en indice
système suisse et des priorités à
respecter sa résume bien les choses
[Musique]
c'est ça donc là gros duel table 1 avec
5 sur 5 en deux joueurs
45 millions karsen avec les plans
un petit pronostic Kevin pour cette
partie
tout le monde et il a les blancs donc
[Musique]
je le vois bien pour l'instant il est
très bien dans le tournoi il a 5 sur 5
du coup je vois bien you et cette
bloquer car le scène et puis pense pas
Carlsen soit du genre à s'envoyer
complètement en l'air même en blitz il
peut contrôler les choses donc je pense
qu'il veut faire sa partie c'est de
pousser avec les blancs comme il fait
d'habitude donc ça marche très bien on
l'a vu contre doubaf quand Douba fallait
sortir une très bonne partie de défense
bah ils avaient fini par faire nul et
c'est c'était pas c'était pas un
problème quoi
non clairement 45 il est il est très
très dur quand il est enfant mais il est
très très dur à arrêter donc là les
blancs contre yongli il reste favori
après bien sûr c'est une grosse partie
il y en a c'est quand même un super
joueur d'échec il y a aussi du Blitz
donc grosse partie à venir et bien sûr
mvl mvl qui va jouer contre du rabahli
qui est un bon grand maître mais mais
qui n'est pas encore enfin c'est pas un
joueur de place mondiale c'est pas un
joueur à 2700 c'est pas un joueur
c'est pas un joueur
et est-ce que tu sais
si les joueurs ont des petites pauses
pour pour déjeuner etc en milieu de
journée etc ou pas du tout j'en ai
absolument aucune idée je ne pense pas
parce que quand je vois juste le les
horaires il y a pas de pause enfin c'est
à 30 minutes chaque partie et ça
enchaîne
donc chez eux en fait le tournoi
commence à 15h tu vois bien sûr donc ce
serait là après ils vont manger plus
tard
mais normalement ils sont censés avoir
mangé avant et surtout ça en fait tout
ça donc
voilà mais non ils ont pas de pause pour
me ranger tu imagines si on ne voit pas
trop tu vois d'ailleurs s'alimenter mais
bon après on voit pas les gradins etc
dans des petites bouteilles d'eau voilà
bon ça va pas tarder à reprendre allez
on va dire dans cinq minutes
donc là je le connais pas c'est fini à
l'écran généralement j'aime bien vous
dire qui passe mais je ne les connais
pas c'est Christiane scène qui est là
bonne soirée qui passe aussi
par Christiane qui a fait un super vidéo
sur la lapine
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qu'il a fait gros
travail
la problématique souvent des vidéos de
Chessy ball je trouve qu'elles sont à la
fois très intéressantes pour nous mais
des fois elle ne vulgarise pas vraiment
l'ouverture quoi c'est vraiment du
travail de ouais c'est ça et du coup
digestes pour les joueurs à plus de 2002
plus de 2000 peut-être mais en dessous
c'est plus difficile
on est d'accord
c'est pour ça que faites attention quand
vous prenez des livres ou des vidéos
regardez un petit peu pour quel niveau
ça s'adresse sinon des fois vous avez
des surprises et vous dites bah le mec
est hyper fort l'ouverture qui conseille
elle est hyper bonne donc ça tout ça
c'est très bien sur le principe mais
c'est vrai que si on commence à rentrer
dans explications assez lointaines
parce que les joueurs vont jouer des
joueurs tellement forts que la théorie
va être respectée et vous savez que dans
votre quotidien de joueur amateurs
encore c'est encore plus vrai si vous
êtes débutant pas que la théorie ne dure
pas véritablement très longtemps quoi
donc il faudra vraiment pour progresser
que vous compreniez les idées
principales autour de l'ouverture
pas de joie ce française du MD c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a pas trop suivi un
événement des fois par petites touches
on nous demande des nouvelles du
championnat du championnat féminin et
pouvoir regarder juste pour vous faire
un petit bilan
c'est la joie chinoise qui a gagné
d'ailleurs le rapide qui qui s'est
qualifié pour
[Musique]
pour la finale des candidates
qui va jouer la finale des candidats
donc là c'est vrai que les premières
places chez les femmes sont trop stay
par par la financement
et je peux rapidement vous dire ma tan
qui aime beaucoup qui aime beaucoup
aussi le blit c'est le disait elle-même
c'est ce qu'elle préfère qui a qui a
gagné le rapide donc hier se retrouve
aussi bien parti dans le tournoi féminin
puisqu'elle a 4 et demi sur 5 pendant
que chuvalova Polina qui est très connu
la mettre dans la salle russe
à 5 sur 5 donc il y a regroupement donc
il y a quatre donc elle a quatre et
demi-tanes contre suvalova 5 et sinon il
y a un Rica et gounina qui ont 4 ennemis
toutes deux suivis d'un gros groupe de 8
joueurs huit joueuses à 4 points voilà
pour ce petit point chez les dames
tout simplement
les femmes peuvent décider de jouer
l'Open mixte dans un endroit mais je
vous rappelle que pour participer à la
peine mixte il faut 2550 minimum donc il
y a pas beaucoup de femmes dans le monde
qui est qui pourrait avoir le droit de
le faire et quand à 2005 50
et bah tu veux être champion du monde de
temps donc en fait
donc en fait voilà là on en a pas si on
avait une ouifane peut-être qu'elle
aurait eu envie de participer avec les
hommes c'est aussi possible pour se
faire plaisir et tout mais bon voilà là
les filles plusieurs femmes pouvaient le
faire un voyage qui est certain temps je
pense que c'était bon aussi parce que là
on a leur hello de en fait tous les
hello annoncent
de Blitz
pour les femmes sont en moins de 25 50
par contre vous savez qu'il y avait
moyen si vous avez plus de 25,50 en
rapide ou en l'an de faire le tournoi
mixte c'est ce que nous disait stouf
donc
certaines joueuses pouvaient le faire il
y avait pas beaucoup de choses à pouvoir
le faire d'ailleurs
l'agneau aussi sans doute
bon bref en tout cas tous on a dit que
en plus
si je les hommes c'est très très
richement doté pour les premiers les
meilleurs les meilleurs joueurs chez les
femmes c'est un peu moins le cas même si
c'est aussi le cas pour les toutes
meilleures mais du coup si on parle
vraiment des prix pour le coup il y a un
intérêt pour une femme qui est 25 50 si
elle gagne le tournoi elle gagne 40 000
dollars
une femme qui a 25 50 qui joue le 31 mix
elle va partir avec zéro quoi
donc déjà sur le plan strictement
financier
ça explique pas mal de choses puis aussi
je veux quand même pour un titre de
champion de champion du monde c'est
quand même quelque chose de différent un
open normal à la limite bon mais là je
prends un titre champion du monde en
vrai crédit on peut expliquer ça par
contre l'imam ne fait pas l'objet de
suspension parce que la triche n'est pas
prouvée et c'est extrêmement difficile
de prouver une triche
c'est exactement comme comme au vélo
tout ça des fois on parle de de
performance inhumaine mais les joueurs
ne sont pas confondus il n'y a que
quasiment le flagrant délice touf pour
pour ce genre de suspension
donc nous perso ben écoute on peut pas
trop trop en parler sur la chaîne on a
eu des consignes et en même temps que
voilà
on peut pas en parler parce que là on
est quand même pas sur nos chaises on
est surferscom faire donc on en parlera
si vous voulez sur nos chaînes je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs que vous envoyez la
petite qui saut on en a plein déjà parlé
à effectivement avec femme j'avais
accueilli au chat qui avait fait des
vidéos sur YouTube sur ma chaîne etc
mais là on représente quand même chascom
comme la distoff en plus
cette affaire concerne aussi chascom
donc il serait très mal avisé de notre
part de d'en parler je pense que vous le
comprenez
voilà galindor tu as bien tu as bien
résumé les choses
et je vais le mettre ton petit saut
aussi souffle si vous voulez nous venons
nous voir pendant qu'on est en stream
sur sur nos belles chaînes et ben
n'hésitez pas vous avez nos
sauf qu'il y a deux U et un f mais c'est
pas grave à part ça c'était presque bien
et en plus il y a un autre streamer qui
qui existe tu vois c'est pas sûr mais en
fait tu peux mettre n'importe quoi il va
quand même le faire
j'ai été tu vois je pensais avoir été
bon cette fois
[Musique]
on a aussi des chaînes YouTube amortisse
tout fait chèque et toi c'est j'imagine
pareil un prévention
n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir sur nos
chaînes YouTube et twitch on pourra
parler de dimensions si vous le
souhaitez
on pourra parler de plein d'autres
choses
donc on fait des échecs on fait beaucoup
de pédagogies et puis tout ça tout ça
soit dans la bonne humeur et voilà
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas ça va grand
plaisir et puis j'ai parlé aussi hier et
je vous le remets de la plateforme de
cours en ligne que j'ai lancé comme
c'est neuf j'en parle et si vous avez
envie d'aller la voir je vous ai mis le
lien dans le chat il y en a certains qui
connaissent et c'est tant mieux donc
n'hésitez pas non plus pour progresser
si vous avez envie de voir des des
vidéos adaptées et ben ça me fera grand
plaisir
la Sicilienne on est plutôt dans des
choses assez standard stouf
donc là c'est mieux je trouve ça les
correspond plus en blitz ça il faut que
je joue quand même les positions qu'ils
dominent
c'est une bonne gueule d'ailleurs ça
sicilienne pour l'instant tout
ouais
rendez-vous le premier samedi de chaque
mois sur la chaîne
en vrai on peut en discuter il y a pas
de souci mais on en parlera sur ma
chaîne mais moi j'ai mes j'ai des
théorie aussi
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec pas mal de
personnes c'est un sujet qui qui
intéresse
oui et puis en dehors du monde des
échases aussi d'ailleurs ouais ouais
donc c'est pour ça il y a un véritable
engouement on a beaucoup on a beaucoup
parlé des échecs
[Musique]
je suis un peu moins fan dans cette
position je sais pas j'aurais bien voulu
taper sur le cavalier il a juste fout
des 8 et n'en mangeant des cinq ça
aurait été une erreur la stratégie qui
est assez grave je pense Kevin parce que
[Musique]
tactique c'est presque tactique au final
mais autant de stratégies
pour le cavalier c'est une grosse épine
dans la pose donc voilà comme tu l'as
dit ne mangez pas toujours les pièces en
dessin comme ça des fois
tu vas gagner des sponsors
bah écoute
pour pour devenir sponsor officiel de
fashion en plus je tise ouais je dise
les gars c'est rendez-vous samedi vous
savez
c'est le 31 peut-être que je fais un
petit stream en milieu d'après-midi ça
pourrait être ça pourrait le faire en
vrai en vrai
ça va dépendre
la forme je risque de me faire de me
faire taper sur les doigts pour ma
copine qui elle va commencer à préparer
à manger bien sûr c'est toujours pas de
Noël repas de Noël de Nouvel An c'est ça
c'est toujours l'équilibre à trouver
pour nous Stéphane en a même contrainte
de trouver du temps pour faire toutes
ces choses là en plus d'être screenshot
en plus des vidéos YouTube en plus des
cours donc on a un agenda bien rempli
les mêmes contraintes approximativement
et du coup
il faut gérer les contraintes perso
qui vient de me donner une un coup vite
je sais pas on pourrait faire un petit
stream à la à la quincaillerie si vous
voulez m'aider à monter mon truc
je vais streamer je vais aller à la
quincaillerie vous allez m'aider à
choisir la moustiquaire et vous allez
gagner à l'installer chez moi parce que
je n'arrive pas à faire
et je pense que ça il y aurait du monde
ah franchement je pense que le jaune
qui va arriver c'est qu'un de la case de
5 mais attention après Dame des quatre
quand il est prévu il a juste fait
instinctivement
dame Descartes avec la case
c'est pas facile d'AMS c'est de la
préférer en face de la Tour C8
jouer pour le pion le pion prend à 5 à
B4 c'est ça qu'il a dû voir prise B4
mais tu reprends 5 du coup hein
[Musique]
je pense quand même puis il y a aussi
quand même le cavalier prend 4 qui peut
être toujours marcher avec ton C3 tu
vois donc
3 je prends là je prends ça trois
il y a des compensation même si pour
l'instant une paire de fou pour les
blancs ici on va voir en tout cas ce qui
se passe mon how to Amy ben écoutez j'ai
pas joué les gars depuis longtemps donc
ça c'est pas facile aussi on en parle du
coup tout a forcément moins le temps de
jouer hein
aussi et
il y a pas de tournois c'est moi enfin
j'ai faim
si tu veux jouer des tournois
mais là je vais jouer en National en
équipe normalement le week-end
du 15 janvier ça ça fait plaisir quand
même
c'est déjà ça attends
c'est trop chaud c'est Max ok c'est mat
donc il ne jouera pas du coup
et cette position n'est pas si facile
pour les blancs qui ont un pion de plus
mais le cavalier est plus fort que le
fou qui est bloqué par le pion des 5
donc ouais
on peut jouer du cavalier d'essai qui a
valu le 5 avec avec un super cavalier
ici donc après manger en 4 pour
directement récupérer le matériel il va
essayer de faire nul maintenant Maxime
vraisemblablement
[Musique]
qui pousse peut-être un petit peu
car c'est qui avec celui qui pousse
c'est pas
clairs
comme ça ça peut être pas mal
donc
en fait en priorité on est quand même
pour mvl on voit le supporter on va
essayer en être avec lui il est champion
du monde en titre donc on va essayer que
de vraiment le voir si on voit qu'il
s'effondre quoi on verra peut-être plus
de partir
donc on va voir un peu comment ça se
passe mais pour l'instant en tant qu'il
est en cours tant qu'il est là on va
plutôt suivre ensemble car elle en
priorité il y a une huile de 45 et là du
coup Maxime qui je vais vous remettre la
position Maxime qui a qui a les noirs
qui a un petit danger mais pas gros
danger parce que il a une tour très
active on a l'impression que le pion on
va être récupéré un soit les blancs F2
il y a le plein échecs soit il prend le
pion et maintenant ben j'ai un pion
passé aussi et je pense que je vais
réussir à récupérer un tour H3 et F4
voilà le pion on va être perdu et il y a
quand même des chances de nul ici à voir
si tu arrives parce que tu vois par
exemple tu reprends reprend ton bras
après sera coupé par la tour
donc c'est compliqué c'est une finale
qui est tellement difficile à trouver la
jauge
et maintenant j'ai ce pion qui peut
avancer
mais encore une fois c'est très
compliqué
[Musique]
j'ai un problème parce que je sais plus
quoi jouer
encore échec il y aura toujours les
chats ça c'est un peu malheureux B7 ça
fait deux pions
[Musique]
et c'est abondant à faire contre durable
qui était on avait dit plutôt un bon
appariment on pensait mais qui est très
très bon blixère aussi
mvl et je pense que
on va on va voir un carcène guéri ou un
quartier de Naka c'est quasi sûr parce
que du coup à 4h30 sur 5 on a que trois
joueurs
on va voir chez parisien si tu veux un
petit poulain Douda exactement
est-ce que j'ai une caméra sur Douda je
veux voir et chez les jeunes femmes on
va assister à une nulle entre schubalova
malheureusement et toi ça fait nul
pas si vous l'avez vu à l'écran qui
avait les blancs
pourtant elle a changé de coupe de
cheveux
un petit peu moins mais
donc sharinganouli
ça donne quoi
ça donne que gangli il va gagner avec
les Noirs ça c'est une finale des fois
assez simple
pas très pas une très bonne opération
première Sarine encore une fois les
parties sont d'un gros gros niveau et il
peut tout se passer
on va Gazi qui va me battre vidite tout
F3 tranquille
qui va arriver à s'abandonner abandon
parce que j'ai trouvé les tours et c'est
terminé c'est le plus simple pour avoir
une forêt ce qui a perdu contre Anton
[Musique]
tous les joueurs sont extrêmement forts
vous l'avez dit
Maxime
on peut si vous voulez voir un peu ce
qui s'est passé dans la partie voilà la
partie Sébastien j'attends que ça charge
et donc c'était une sylliane Rossolimo
que Sébastien aime beaucoup le plus
tranquille sans risque donc le petit P3
et là direct il s'engouffe dans la
finale pour aller chercher oui il a pris
une sans doute une mauvaise décision il
n'a pas osé bouffer GSM mais
c'est peut-être pas obligé de donner le
n'était pas obligé de donner quand même
sa paire de fou pour pas grand chose
[Musique]
la position il peut plus rien faire
et Jules qui a gagné
je vais changer je vais changer le score
sur le stream donc qui rejoue son temps
anglaise tranquille max
avec tour c'est un Caballero 4 dams2 bon
les positions que vu l'aime bien quoi
blanche ça c'est ça c'est le rêve pour
les blancs
c'est le rêve pour les blancs garder un
petit peu le côté le côté vers là-bas
toutes les cartes blanches ouvertes la
paire de fou qui qui se balade couleur
maintenant on peut ouvrir la position
regarder le fouet 3 et le fouet froid
récompensé c'est joli la petite manœuvre
j'ai trois on va venir bloquer la case
de cave on mange ça et Jules qui a fait
très très bonne partie il est grand
maître en face à mais on a pas
l'impression parce que Jules joue très
bien
des fois quand c'est c'est il y a enfin
quand il y a une grosse partie d'un
joueur et ben on a l'impression que le
genre en face a fait une mauvaise partie
mais en fait vu de là était vraiment
intraitable moi il a tout fait il a pris
l'initiative et fait mal tout au long de
la partie
dur dur yes très très dur donc du coup
toutes les parties sont terminées on est
pile pile à la moitié sauf de la journée
et puis la moitié je vais vous mettre le
score est-ce que tu veux poser une
petite pause
[Musique]
une petite pause les gars et puis on
revient d'ici 5 minutes histoire de les
manger un truc de bouger un petit peu je
vais vous laisser la vue de la caméra la
caméra avec tous les joueurs je pense
c'est cool et puis et puis écoutez je
vous dis
Adam avant 5 minutes donc restez 20
minutes sur le chat on revient dans dans
un instant pour tout de suite pour
souffler un petit peu à tout de suite
tout de suite
et nous sommes de retour et oui c'était
la petite pause café ouais alors je vais
en profiter pour vous montrer un petit
peu le classement cool jusqu'à
maintenant donc là sur le testcom
malheureusement je l'ai que les 20
premières mais on peut voir qu'on a
qu'un scène avec youngui et
avec
5 et demi sur 6 suivi de
six joueurs à 5 sur 6 donc gangolis
tu sais il avait perdu très rapidement
bah il est revenu ma mère c'est pareil
ma mère
qui sont montés à 5 sur 6 du coup 5
tendres d'affilée avec bien sûr la 4h30
beaucoup de monde on voit on a laservic
on a dudat abdos il y a beaucoup de
monde à 4h30 attendu que Maxime du coup
et arrêtez laissé à 5 points vraiment à
quatre points sur 6 donc voilà je vais
vous remettre ma foutu moi un ennemi
reste beaucoup de ronde on vous l'a dit
on est à la moitié de la première
journée il y a 12 secondes aujourd'hui
et seulement 9 demain
on aura une tendance parmi les favoris
pour eux parce que là ils sont pas
encore assis ils prennent leur temps et
je pense que du coup on a bien fait de
faire le repos dans ce moment-là Kevin
parce que du coup
complètement ouais
le bon timing on a senti les choses sauf
ça a été tu as été bon sur ce coup-là
ouais ben ça faisait quand même ouais le
string qui va durer environ 7 heures
donc c'est vrai que
au bout de trois heures trois heures et
demie c'est cool enfin petite pause
avant d'enchaîner
dans la deuxième partie et pâte à tout
compris en fait comme on a décidé de
faire une pause le tournoi décidé aussi
de se mettre en pause évidemment
on a des exigences avec stouffe qu'on a
envie de se faire un petit café
de la chaîne
[Rires]
si moi je veux en tant que Chauvin tu
sais on en a parlé tout à l'heure
21 parties
on en a joué pour l'instant 6
aujourd'hui et neuf demain donc pour
l'instant rapide parce que hier c'était
la fin du chemin du monde de rapides
mais ils enchaînent les deux les joueurs
pour que ce soit beaucoup plus facile
ainsi
hier c'était le rapide il y aura rapide
sur deux jours sur trois jours hein
d'accord avec 13 parties
et du coup aujourd'hui comment est-ce le
tournoi de Blitz maintenant la cadence 3
+ 2 et du coup 22 parties de 3 + 2 c'est
il y a deux trois différents plat du
monde de partir rapide et champion du
monde de parties de Blitz
et donc Willy fait un très beau tournoi
on peut le citer aussi salut à tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent
donc c'est un joueur à 2600-2650 il fait
même des Open un peu maintenant
confidentiel je l'ai vu faire un tournoi
il y a pas si longtemps en Bretagne bref
ganglais il joue aussi pour le top le
Top 16 de masfisher
c'est un client mais de là le retrouver
à 5 sur 6
grosse perf grosse paire
pas facile
si vous le souhaitez donc ronde 7 on a
10 ricardson table 1 on a yu-yangi
Nakamura du coup table 2 donc c'est les
quatre joueurs en tête avec 5 et demi et
en plus
quasiment sûr les joueurs commencent à
s'installer et ça tombera à 13h30 ça a
l'air logique
donc il y a eu après il y a plein
d'appareillements qui sont très
intéressants comme bluebom
etc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gros
chocs et Maxime qui du coup j'aurais à
table 12 qui est noir contre riansf donc
Maxime qui a un point et demi de retard
sur sur le peloton de tête qui va devoir
du coup enchaîner la victoire pour pour
remonter donc il a encore beaucoup il a
le temps encore il a encore si partout
aujourd'hui neuf appartements ça fait 15
parties pour revenir mais attention que
n'a qu'à moi et Carlson c'est vraiment
dégoût deux grosses locomotives et il
faut pas les perdre de vue
c'était mon partenaire de club quand
j'étais à masse Fisher c'est notre
numéro 1 il a été plus de 2007 donc
c'est un joueur très dangereux c'est pas
si facile que ça
pour mvl après cette défaite contre
douloureuse contre du Rabahi
puisque
il avait au moins la nul je pense enfin
rassurer
dans cette dans cette partie après c'est
pas facile avec les pieds noirs vraiment
pas la partie était plutôt jolie c'était
une sienne assez esthétique dans les
règles de l'art mais ça a mal tourné
dans la finale
on a quand même un choc là francophone
assez intéressant on a table 46 darda
avec les Blancs contre Jules Moussard
donc dardages c'est le joueur
la star entre nous pas de métal contre
nous
donc c'est un peu la star belge qui il a
que 16 ans alors il a 2600 hello
à peu près 2110
en tout cas
et c'est passé Mazet joue table 77 il a
deux points et il va affronter un joueur
un joueur à 2217
voilà
l'arbitrage stouffe je vais faire une
compet irréelle aujourd'hui j'aimerais
savoir c'est quoi la diff licence AOB
est-ce que avec la B je peux faire des
compètes Fides ça je crois pas et avoir
les lots rapides quand même ça je crois
mais l'orage alors oui alors pour le
match de 92 si tu veux jouer des
licences en fait ça dépend ce que tu
veux jouer la licence a te permet de
faire tout le tournoi que tu veux en
France absolument tous toutes les
cadences possibles à essence B te permet
de faire coder de tournoi cadence rapide
et Blitz
donc la cadence enfin les tournois
commencent feed enfin Blitz pardon et
rapide vont être Fides normalement donc
tu peux les faire donc ça contrat pour
ton vélo par contre les vrais
compétitions qui sont des parties lentes
tout ça ça comptera pas pour enfin tu
pourras pas les faire enfin ta parole de
faire tu peux les faire que si tu veux
une après il y a une grosse différence
il y a une grosse différence de de de
prix entre la licence B je crois que
c'est du style c'est un plumes mais
c'est difficile genre 45 euros contre 10
euros un truc comme ça
mais voilà quoi mais je crois pas contre
je crois par contre j'ai pas les lofides
même en rapide normalement
quand tu fais
trop précis en fait le match je voudrais
que enfin tu vois c'est un tout petit
peu spécifique comme question parce que
la licence B en fait elle est là pour
vraiment démarrer la compétition
surtout utilisé pour les scolaires et
pour les adultes c'est le premier pas en
compote et après souvent les joueurs
passent à la licences a pour faire des
des vraies compétitions comme le disait
soupe en l'an par contre c'est une bonne
alternative la licence B si tu fais que
des rapides évidemment maintenant est-ce
que tu auras un hello fille en plus en
rapide
je peux pas te dire je vois que tu as
l'ambition le mage de passer les 25 50
et de faire le championnat du monde de
rapides l'an prochain je pense que c'est
pour ça ah Gaïa va nous répondre et là
c'est
possible tournoi automobile oui voilà
après il y a des galets
rapides sont quasiment tous filles donc
pardon tu vois d'ailleurs c'est marrant
parce que la semaine dernière j'ai fait
un tournoi de de Blitz à Las Palmas là
où j'habite
sur neuf en ratant en matant un coup
dans une partie que j'ai fait nul bref
tellement voilà et du coup j'ai gagné 30
points hello feed à peu près et moi qui
a un élo Blitz un petit peu bas bon
j'étais content je me tiens je remonte
un peu tu vois OK et comme c'était un
tournoi qui était un peu caritatif tu
vois en fait pour l'inscription il
fallait offrir un jouet en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que comme c'est
caritatif et ben ils ont pas pris cette
homologué
ah c'est bon
pour une fois que je suis un bon
tendresse
en même temps tu fais le tournoi à jouer
club
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné un énorme un
énorme j'ai vu ta photo sur insta je
crois
tu veux pas être malheureux avec ton
poignet garni d'ailleurs j'ai annoncé
mon Instagram aussi sur l'instant
Instagram d'échec que j'ai encore
quasiment rien fait les gars j'ai juste
mis le feu de moi avec mon petit
panigarnie
tu vois je l'ai vu tout donc ça a marché
mais je compte je compte faire bientôt
mettre pas mal de contenu et chacun
aussi sur Instagram donc pour ceux qui
veulent me suivre mon Instagram c'est
tout fait chèque donc n'hésitez pas à
venir me follow sur sur insta c'est
c'est gratuit et vous aurez vous aurez
pas de Pikachu vous aurez pas de place
nudiste mais vous aurez du contenu
d'échec de qualité on espère on pourra
peut-être mêler les deux hein le joint
de liquide à l'agréable ouais voilà
après on verra peut-être un jour un
petit stream aussi sur la plage je pense
que pandruks il paierait pour ça en tout
cas
bref
il y a marqué qu'ils prennent en compte
et leur rapide et hellofides mais je
crois que pour avoir un hélophile faut
la 1 et que donc ils prennent en compte
aH ça c'est trop spécifique le mal
malheureusement c'est vraiment ça la
question dommage on a bien compris ta
question mais c'est difficile d'y
répondre il y a que Gaia qui peut
répondre parce qu'elle est vraiment
arbitre non pas professionnel mais
officiel a pas plein trop non plus mais
très très régulièrement donc elle avant
de toutes ses règles là je remercie en
direct live méditerfa pour me follow sur
insta
ça a marché les gars ça a marché donc
j'ai créé le compte y a quoi il y a une
semaine et j'ai encore rien fait j'ai
beaucoup de travail mais c'est j'ai
ambition de de faire un truc un peu sur
instable pour pour ça peut être sympa
voilà
j'ai du mal à tout suivre je t'avoue
voilà maintenant continue
du coup Maxime je suis pas fan de ce qui
de ce qui fait il y a ce pion c'est
c'est une grosse cible quand même tu
vois donc c'est sa grande folle
classique mais effectivement il est un
peu vissé
il est un peu vissé et puis je trouve
qu'il est un peu en difficulté il a du
mal à s'activer il y a une position des
plantes qui quand même très très solide
avec deux pions au centre il y a la
paire de fou quand même pour les noirs
qui a Maurice qui a Maurice qui a suivi
le qui a suivi l'EHPAD de super TF1
vous avez été bon
ouais
ce qui se passe aussi dans d'autres
parties maximum en soumission en tout
cas mais il va jouer vite maximum je
peux vous dire et je pense que si il
peut se faire avoir là-dessus qui est
qui est pas qui a pas une très bonne
position là donc on va voir ce qui se
passe
non plutôt que c'est pas du tout terminé
pour pour Maxime mais encore 15 parties
intimes pas ça tourne vite d'ailleurs
l'année dernière il a fait une remontada
de l'espace dans les dernières parties
d'affilée pour revenir donc donc
t'inquiète pas c'est encore beaucoup de
parties il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
parties encore à jouer donc
je pense que tout va bien encore on est
marrant de la position de d'Aniche et de
Magnus avec des cartes noires
une structure
une structure affaibli ce côté blanc
mais les cases noires en compensation
donc c'est compliqué à juger le roi
blanc qui se balade un petit peu il y a
une structure affaiblie comme tu l'as
dit mais il y a des pions aussi qui sont
faibles un peu de partout et c'est une
position fermée mais qui peut s'ouvrir à
tout moment elle a par défaut pour les
blancs ce qui est pas forcément bien
quand la potion est fermée tu vois
et en tout cas il est vraiment vraiment
derrière autant on l'a précisé ça c'est
vrai que c'est plus plus étonnant
il est pas en grande forme là on voit
qu'il a quelques secondes après la
partie on voit que le genre joue et que
la partie ne joue pas donc peut-être que
ce qu'il est arrivé en retard non mais
tu vois il y a un problème de
transmission c'était étonnant un peu le
temps 40 à une 40 au final ça a buggé
maintenant la finale paraît pas très
très agréable pour manusa
que la paire de fou plus le pion passé
à l'aile dame indique il va y avoir
il va y avoir du dur pour Magnus
le pion passé avec la paire de fou c'est
très très fort comme tu le dis bien
quand même il vient de faire mettre
toute la position il va se rendre tout
en B1 tours bien ces quatre fermeture de
position le faux 2 va attirer mort alors
que il n'était pas obligé
voilà il s'est fait enfermer le fou
c'est un peu dommage à niche il a il
s'est trompé
les affaires de Magnus tout ça
^
maximum
je crois retourner à la vapeur on peut
aller voir Maxime si vous voulez deux
secondes
il y a Maxime qui allait noir a réussi à
prendre l'avantage regardez il a le pion
qui va avancer le pire passé mais la
plus de temps regarde malheureusement je
pense que il avait fait la course devant
ça pourrait bien leur lancer ma fille
dans ce tournoi
je pense qu'il va gagner maintenant avec
une minute contre 20 secondes et cette
position qui semble technique mais
favorable
en tout cas pour les blancs c'est
difficile à Jean pratique on retourne on
est sur plusieurs personnes en même
temps c'est difficile en blitz
malheureusement on va tout faire en même
temps mais en tout cas on essaie de de
voir le maximum ensemble donc quand
donne le pion à schisme voilà et qu'à en
scène se dit qui va le récupérer le pion
h quand elle va jouer hein
un fou qui ne jouera jamais et même si
ce que j'ai trop un jour ça sert à quoi
m'en fous je jouera pas même si voilà le
fou il est complètement enfermé derrière
la structure donc là positionnellement
grâce à une qui a vous avez vu c'est un
atypique deux fous croix de cavalier
dans la potion fermée les Cavés sont
meilleurs c'est vraiment un exemple
incroyable c'est un exemple les Noirs
c'est un super avantage aux échecs mais
quand la pollution est fermée les fous
peuvent rien faire malheureusement ils
sont enfermés derrière leur position
alors que les cavaliers eux ils peuvent
se fourrer un petit peu où ils veulent
un peu partout j'ai dit ruptures alors
que les Blancs pas de rupture c'est pas
encore clair on n'est pas sûr que quand
ça ne va la gagner du cavalier fourré on
la retiendra celle là
on a appris des trucs quand même la
cabane etc le cadre du
fourrez avec avec Kevin et moi
sur sur les stream
en force et l'option h est coincé c'est
fini c'est fini incroyable et en plus
vous voyez que le fou ici d'ailleurs il
a il a abandonné je crois guéri dans la
partie il abandonné là on voit le joueur
qui parle et
dégoûté guéri parce qu'il était
complètement mieux il le sait et il lui
dit
ah oui la paire de fou qu'il a enfermé
lui-même il s'est fait enfermer le foie
fin il a perdu la partie
qui a sa finale avec un pion de plus qui
n'est pas ainsi sur notre gagnante parce
que
en fait le roi blanc est coupé c'est une
très bonne chose le roi pourra jamais
venir à la défense
du pion si le roi blanc était ici je
pense ce serait nul assez facile avec
Laurent Blanc qui est coupé et ben du
coup ça fait une pièce de moins pour les
bords pour devenir vraiment participer à
l'attaque il a des chances pratiques
mais c'est dur quand même à gagner
objectivement quand je pousse le pion
très souvent les blancs vont vouloir
sacrifier leur cavaliers sur la sur le
pion et je joue cette finale qui est
théoriquement nulle mais en pratique
extrêmement difficile à tenir on va
assister sans doute un roi turfu c'est
peut-être la meilleure chance maintenant
tout parce que Maxime réussit à trouver
de l'initiative les pièces sont belles
et avec les Blancs
il faut absolument éviter une finale
ou le pion avancerait serait trop trop
embêtant il y a des risques
voilà maxime est en train de travailler
pour promouvoir tout simplement son
Pione il va passer son fond d'écran à un
moment c'est certain pour essayer un E3
sont en train de ranger les pièces qui a
gagné
donc ça fait
Naka et guéri les seuls joueurs avec
si c'est mis sur 7 on fait tourner la
boîte on n'a pas de risque véritable
avec les noirs
il bouge le roi il y a un jour il va
pousser le pion mais un jour dans les
bonnes conditions
on va essayer d'accompagner
aussi un jour avec une sorte de
découverte
et ce qui va y avoir un petit peu
travailler loin maintenant le cavalier
de riazon
E5 malheureusement il menace et kg G4 on
a vu la jauge nous indiquer qu'il y
avait sûrement eu un petit quelque chose
à moi pour Maxime et ça va vite pour
tout le monde
sont obligés de jouer à fond la caisse
les deux joueurs à ce petit jeu là je
vois bien Maxime poser un problème à un
moment à Riaz ans de SAF il a la
position la plus simple à jouer pour pas
qu'il oublie
[Musique]
un moment sur sur Maxime ouais on espère
les joueurs non plus le temps tout
anticiper très clairement
ça peut faire mal
je t'entends marche apparemment tu Obs
dites-moi si c'est
si vraiment il y a un problème pour mon
micro aussi ou si ça marche mousse à
gagner ok
pas de métal et dag ah ça y est on a un
roi tour faucon droit tour on entend
bien en fait on a 50 coups maintenant à
venir pour Maxime
82e coup donc on a jusqu'au 130 deuxième
coup pour gagner cette partie avec
Maxime moi je pense que rien danser va
tenir tu en penses quoi moi je pense pas
en prendre Paris
on fait quelque chose bien ici
et qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi je
réfléchis Maxime
tous les jours Maxime les deux joueurs
vont vont jouer il a gagné pourquoi
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
facilement perdu pour moi
[Musique]
ça c'est bizarre cette histoire il a
vraiment gagné je pense qu'il a vraiment
gagné
on peut voir ben on a eu ça
échec là
[Musique]
sur la bande c'est déjà très difficile
ça bug ouais il y a beaucoup de
partitions
c'est tout ça sur un autre spot post-it
mais là on est contre déjà du rapide et
je mets deux subvers mvl tofu
c'est en plus
merci à riz à
Andrew tank c'est c'est le genre qui est
qui est à gauche dans la caméra
qui a des blancs dans cette partie tu
vois genre Internet les blancs vont
gagner facilement
[Musique]
c'est incroyable quand même incroyable
vous allez comme ça
je crois qu'il a joué en fait ça gagne
pas malheureusement
tout ça pour la perdre alors qu'il a dû
dominer son adversaire
pour tous les joueurs
en plus tant que c'est vraiment le
joueur d'Internet hyper fort ambulette
tout ça tu vois qui qui au final
[Musique]
et là du coup bah il faut plus cliquer
il faut jouer
exactement faut bouger et il a perdu
autant donc là ça
si vous voulez qui sont terminés mais
que nous ils nous marquent c'est pas
terminé donc je vais attirer la page
c'est de voir si j'ai bizarre sur cette
fin de ronde
et Maxime a gagné et ça ça nous fait
plaisir quand même et j'y croyais pas
vous avez vu ça me fait très plaisir et
Moussa qui a battu darda
et Bastien
de Jules contre
assez rare dans ce tournoi donc c'est
c'est très bien alors
bien fixé avec tous les pièces sur la
position de fin sur la première rangée
une attaque t'aurais
5 plutôt bien joué avec qui empêche le
qui empêche le rock qui avait le 5
ouverture blanche
il y a un problème sur le rock on arrive
pas à ok donc là il y a eu pion prend je
pense qu'il comprend pour enlever le
joli cavalier E5
béton il avait tiens on va le virer et
on mange
B21 Damas 3 en mange deux petits pions
père B7 et puis on a maintenant plus
avec les Noirs donc on est assez content
ici
prise prise l'option qui c'est qui était
prenable mais j'ai peut-être dû tu ouais
c'était fini en fait si tu manges
j'avais A2 suivi de Caval et B4
du coup il y a pas eu ça il y a eu
cavalle Decathlon et en fait un peu la
même chose
et la Tour Blanche ne joue pas regardez
le cadavres
c'est l'horreur donc là
grosse grosse victoire de de de Jules
qui a quand même bien pris le dessus sur
son
patriote mais sur son voisin francophone
[Musique]
les super grand maître Carl Sénégal
à 5 sur 7 Jules à 4 sur 7 et Sébastien 3
sur 7 je vais vous montrer les les
je peux faire comme hier je pense c'est
les standings pas mal super la partie de
Seb Seb qui avait les noirs sont dans on
a le temps avoir un joueur maintenant un
peu plus modeste quand même un joueur à
après il faut les battre quand même ce
jour-là
très en forme dans le tournoi donc il a
choisi l'ouverture est indienne pour
déséquilibrer la position et la
travailler sur case noire
une position où là pas très très bien
quand même
c'est franchement c'est pas ce qu'il a
fait c'était pas terrible sur A6 qui va
se prendre à 5 en plus
donc il a fixé tous les dames
et là il est pas bien
ça c'est faut prendre F4 à revenir
complètement dans la partie là avec le
petit tour de passe H4 pour moi c'est
pas un très bon coup vous savez dans les
stands
quand même pour les Noirs là ils donnent
toutes les cases à l'adversaire ça c'est
pas du tout très joli pour
pour le noir qui au fur et à mesure vont
prendre vont prendre l'avantage parce
que le Caval dans le 5 il est monstrueux
le cavalier vous voyez que la meilleure
c'est joli
cadre
où est-ce que je pourrais améliorer mon
cahier sur quelle case je voudrais le
mettre en D4 et ben il a tout compris
Sébastien s'il avait su le Cavalier
Blanc l'aurait peut-être échangé quand
il est venu en C7
en fait tu vois
[Musique]
parce que il aurait pu
être du mal tourné il était matin bon là
en plus
c'était bien mais en gardant le pion
c'est une partie
qui aurait pu mal tourner
il a fait après la cavalcade l'envoler
lyrics du roi et il a réussi à bananer
son adversaire qui s'est fait mater ou
quasi
ça fait penser un petit Bullet sur
chasse point comme cette partie il y en
a Seb nous a déjà fait mieux il y a eu
des belles choses mais c'était
inconstant
oui
d'avoir gagné la prochaine partie ça va
être
icarunaka je crois qu'il y a c'est les
deux joueurs qui sont en tête je vais
les carreaux Magnus parce que tu nous as
fait un ni carunaka on a senti que
un lycaro Magnus et c'est le cas donc on
a on a table 1
icarbonate avec les Blancs contre Magnus
Carlson
depuis hier ça sera le grand format je
pense tout fin parce que là on peut pas
rater ça on va le regarder parce qu'on
peut on peut pas passer à côté de ça
c'est la partie entre les deux meilleurs
joueurs au monde lancer dans ces
format-là table 2 on aura fait deux CF
contre du bof et qui perd la première il
fait 6 sur 6 après c'est c'est fort
aussi hein
et de boivent que c'est un spécialiste
un de ces cadences du bave de nul 5
victoires d'affilée après bon c'est les
gros joueurs là
avec 6 contre 5 et demi qui vient de
perdre lui contre
et puis après on a pas mal de joueurs à
5 et demi et Maxime qui a 5 et qui
affronte avec les Blancs un genre qui a
5 et demi c'est 500 ans donc avec les
Blancs ok c'est pas le meilleur
appareillement mais c'est apparemment
qui correct
qui est plus fort et qui a des blancs et
qui va et qui va essayer de d'aller
battre Champlan
mais cette partie là je pense que oui on
va essayer de suivre peut-être 45 c'est
être le match pour le titre c'est les
deux joueurs qui sont seules en tête qui
se qui se joue
qui a un appareil moi assez favorable à
4 points qui jouent en 2462 donc il peut
revenir à 5 et attention que lui il est
dangereux d'ailleurs lui il a battu
Julien
il a battu Julie hier il fait déjà un
super tournoi il a battu sintarov il a
battu Taris il a battu un autre joueur à
2006 il a battu Richard rapport
tu vois il a bien pas il y a pas de
pénom même à 4 hein de toute façon il y
a pas de match facile c'est ça un peno
clairement pas et on voit que le gazy à
trois et demi il pêche à trois et demi
moi qui l'ai mis 5e je vais pas gagner
grand chose avec ça ouais mais déjà il y
a eu le tofu gagnant en une minute ou 30
secondes tu vois déjà
peut-être comment j'ai parié c'est déjà
fini tu sais
un grand maître à 25 70
avec stouve de Magnus donc je pense
qu'on sera tous les deux à ces partisans
d'une victoire de Magnus mais attention
attention le Ghana k on sait très bien
que c'est sac cadence de prédilection
et ça va être dur très clairement
ça va pas être une promenade de santé
c'est parti grosse partie grosse partie
qui arrive là donc dans quelques
instants on va vous mettre la vue de la
grande cam quand même
pour attendre les joueurs et
de la vie pour mettre au slack grande
cam pour 45 pour les voir pour les voir
en vrai avec le petit échiquier c'est
pas mal j'aime bien cette vue là
c'est appréciée hier est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on mette pour cette partie car
celle Naka qu'on mette
la grande caméra avec le tout petit
échiquier ou est-ce que vous préférez la
caméra
normale que j'étais normal
en blitz ça va vite du coup des fois sur
le chéquier on a des petits lags et là
on voit plus les expressions des joueurs
peut-être c'est mieux les grandes
caméras je sais pas qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
mais effectivement je trouve que c'est
vraiment plus sympa je peux vous faire
les mimiques des joueurs
grande cam petit échiquier aussi pour
Gaïa
comme hier c'était bien pas de masse OK
des sublimes tout ce que tu as fait avec
moi apparemment hier selon ce gif
ah oui donc avec ça avec ça
c'est quasiment obligé avec je vous ai
fait une petite garder pour aller voter
entre la petite et la grande caméra
c'est en dessous du chat juste en
dessous n'hésitez pas à voter autant que
vous êtes pour pour ce que vous préférez
la grande de la petite
pas de blague Kevin j'ai voté aussi j'ai
le droit de voter tu vois à voter est-ce
que je peux voter moi je suis pas sûr
que je puisse voter
j'étais voir si je pouvais voter j'ai
voté
aussi
j'ai voté
allez allez faut voter
ça arrive
voilà la grande c'est ça vous aurez une
grande caméra avec nos têtes aussi et
plus petit
il y aura les joueurs sur la grande bien
sûr
ça c'est la grande et ensuite ensuite
ouais pour le chéquier c'est tout petit
c'est vrai c'est pas très grand mais
regardez si je vous mets un échiquier ça
donne ça vous verrez bien les chic et
autrement vous verrez bien les filles
on aura de belles vues je pense en plus
regardez voilà ce sera comme ça et je
pense qu'on aura en plus de meilleurs
vœux parce que du coup comme c'est la
partie à suivre je pense qu'il y aura il
y aura au nord de très belles vues sur
sur
sur les caméras
vous voyez un des caméraman qui sont là
pour l'événement et pour le couvrir et
faire des prises de vues
c'est le rendez-vous de ce tournoi donc
donc du coup on aura de je pense
plusieurs vues possibles et
la grande Cam a écrasé la petite touffe
la grande
du coup bah on va rester là-dessus je
vais mettre le casse il a sa table 3 la
cam numéro 3 c'est la table de 45 mais
il y a aussi le mixcam qui est du coup
une
comment dire la caméra si vous voulez
qui
qui bouge en fait et la caméra qui bouge
et ben elle peut être pas mal par
exemple elle va être sympa la mixcam à
mon avis sauf parce qu'ils vont
s'attarder sur Carlson ils ont plusieurs
prises de vue tout ça ça peut être la
muscade en fait c'est celle là je vous
la montre
celle que vous avez ici bon là pour
l'instant on s'en fout un peu de cesoirs
là c'est pas du tout ce qu'on recherche
mais
vous voyez que elle bouge elle est là
donc du coup je pense à une caméra qui
va être quasi sûr elle va être sur
Carlson Naka
c'est une bonne remarque il nous dit 83%
vs 18 % ce qui nous fait un joli 101%
c'est bien vu on nous laisse rien passer
en tout cas Edelweiss c'était marrant
bien vu
faut pas nous croire sur parole il faut
être curieux ça marche pareil dans les
commentaires qu'on vous donne
échiquellement parlant il faut essayer
de les remettre en cause pour progresser
se poser des questions et nous poser des
questions qu'on vous comprenez pas
quelque chose tout à l'heure dans le
chat il y a quelqu'un qui nous demandait
pourquoi à d'où ça torov avait abandonné
ou perdu autant alors qu'il semblait
gagnant pour l'ordinateur et et oui il y
avait un coût caché c'est assez rigolo
comme n’hésitez pas s'il y a des parties
même que vous voulez qu'on voit ou si
vous avez des questions et ce que vous
ne comprenez pas bon ça emblée ça va
très très vite mais en tout cas s'il y a
des choses qui se passent que vous ne
comprenez pas ou quoi que ce soit
n'hésitez pas on est là pour ça on est
là pour vous aider donc à vous expliquer
un peu ce qui se passe dans ce
championnat donc on est en tout cas à
votre disposition donc vous nous écrivez
dans le chat et puis on vous on vous
répondra quoi
on peut jouer j'ai trois premiers le
mage il y a pas de souci tout comme B3
Magnus d'ailleurs j'ai trois non c'est
mieux que B3 que je joue Magnus
allègrement là dans ce tournoi en fait
avec les Blancs tu as le droit de tout
faire parce que même si je vois un
couple croyable bah tu avais le tempo
d'avance au départ avec les Noirs c'est
vraiment beaucoup moins le cas et ça a
commencé
on voit sur la caméra
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
je trouve que cette vue là elle est
quand même bien sympa
et en plus la vue qui va changer on aura
plusieurs caméras dessus
et il met du temps à jouer son premier
coup alors qu'il est là 15 secondes pour
jouer cavalier F6 c'est rigolo quand
même mais il veut rentrer dans la partie
ils vont être concentrés c'est ça c'est
rigolo il prend son temps et on joue du
coup une position avec dessin c'est une
sorte de de Nimzo
pour l'instant Kevin on va voir s'il
faut le dire c'est simple il joue une ce
qu'on appelle une semi-tarache
en tout cas là les cames sont bien on
regarde le mixcam stuff tu nous envoies
du rêve
ouais je pense qu'ils sont pas mal quand
même pour cette ronde là c'est vraiment
pas mal en fait vous voyez en blitz ça
va vite
donc je pense c'est cool de voir c'est
c'est vu là on voit vraiment les
extensions des joueurs
qui rigolo c'est que nous frappe pas les
mêmes mimiques en stream tout à fait
quand même moi je l'ai vu faire des je
t'ai vu faire des bimmicks c'était quand
c'était une partie qu'il a joué contre
ingit hier en tournant rapide ou en fait
et ben indique a refusé la nul face à
Naka et la qualité mort de rire il a
fait beaucoup de le coup d'après en fait
ou la refusé la nul il a fait une mimi
qui mais qui a duré 10 secondes
insupportable
compte Carlson il le fera moins il peut
le faire un peu mais pas
beaucoup plus et puis mais bon il fera
un petit peu
sûrement